That's fresh.
Yes, we're live. Ladies and gentlemen,
we're live and we're here to
talk about Brendan Schaub shoes.
Those fucking shoes that you wore
to the Mayweather. Mcgregor fight.
What in the fuck you bought? Those are
they, someone gave new and some opinion.
Aware. Yeah. Fill me duties. Paying
me like Jared Leto sense what?
Brian sent you a video of him. I was
like, Oh God, he's going to judge me.
He's going to judge me so hard and it's
part of you though. I like it, man.
Fanny pack.
I got to shut the fuck up no matter any,
any time where there's any
sort of fashion discussion.
I just got to shut the fuck on. He
backs make sense though. The only,
the only tap shoes you are you like a
handmade from from Britain are delicious.
Lots of black hole. What the fuck is
that about? Game of Thrones shits.
I'm Khaleesi buckle that. I just can't
get a number. What's the beat and the bag?
Is that a B? It's a gold be sun.
I get more cots. Gold? Yeah.
Is this like one of those that black or
blue dress thing or it just looks weird
picture. I get more compliments on
the shoes then any shoe I've ever had.
And then hold on. Mr. Ryan, you,
you're six foot four gorilla scared of
no j Lo I saw Jayla she goes up your
shoes. She goes, I love your
shoes. I want, she does.
She's a check the check station code
sign while she's probably also trying to
make a rod jealous cause they probably
been together long enough where she's
starting to feel bored. Yeah, he,
Raj was just trying to basic
the crackle going Jamie,
does that look like gold to you or am
I going blind? That's a gold beach.
Go, go back up to that. Let's go ahead
and see that the bucket was like silver.
Yeah, I guess so. Go Lock.
Make it larger on that.
Oh is it?
I mean I just don't get the hate on
those but I'm looking at him and they are
gorgeous. It's so gross. And
then on top of them being gross,
they have sneaker lasers which
makes him even more stupid ass.
It's just not for you. I guess. It's
like a light gold. I'm thinking of like,
you know like hold on that
one. Oh No, you're right. How?
Wow. Wow. Those are gold TV
suck. Is it a contrast then?
That one looks different.
That one's better. That looks
totally like good.
I have to walk the red carpet after
Bruce Willis in those shoes and some guy
goes, killer boots man. Like a dumb and
dumber. I'm like, yeah, Bruce Willis,
that old ass can't pull these off.
Everyone started laughing,
but I think he heard it. I was like,
Oh, Mr. Die hard. Please, please don't.
Please don't judge me,
but I will.
We'll kick you and these things don't
get it twisted. The St the movies.
Yeah. There's something
about like leaving that foot,
that buckle mark on someone's forehead.
Embarrassing just for claim guy and
skinny jeans and those boots whooped your
ass.
That's embarrassing.
Do you remember when Pete Williams
had kicked Mark Coleman? Oh my God.
It was just like, why can't the
world sound like a bat? It was a,
it was also like one of like what
the fuck? Like, who saw that comment?
Like we thought that Pete who was a
young guy is dealing with Coleman who was
just all super gorilla,
Super Carrillo and then you know,
Pete wore his ass out and landed
that perfectly place head kick.
If he had that buck on dead,
you would see that mark forever.
That Gucci. Gucci. Yeah. I mean Pika,
I'm tired people. I'm such a bad
mother fucker back here it is.
Boom. Got that Async label
on his face though. Yeah.
Damn Joy. The may six, that was
a big, that was a bad week when,
damn that dude is steak and
chicken drug tests. See that.
If you had that mark like that,
like your boots on boom.
And just I'm thinking
Hootchie Gootchie baby. Yeah.
If you notice Pete kicked him to choose
on last fights that you can kick people.
He thinks I'm more like with
the point. Yeah. Hell yeah. Uh,
doing a wheel kick, like a
spinning heel. Chicken some boots.
Yeah, I guess. I think with the heel
kicked out, quite honestly doesn't,
I don't think it matters.
It lands, it lands well.
It's so there's so much power
in that cake. And if you land,
you're landing with your
heel and your heel can,
it's not like a knuckle at breaks
and he never break your, he'll never,
I did hit somebody wants so hard that
my foot was sore and I was limping for a
couple days where the heel kick
with a heel kiss was horrible.
It was hit the hell out of them.
He went to sleep for a long time.
They took him to the house. It
was scary. I was 19. That's bad.
I think I didn't tell you this story
is a fucked up story because it made me
reconsider.
Fighting wrote and killed.
He guy was this a thing I said to my
instructor because my instructor wasn't
there cause he's in California. I was
in, I was in Boston and uh, he goes,
I heard you had a really good
knockout, you know, exact
same. Yeah. And I go, yeah,
it was,
it was scary.
I go a condom with a wheel kick and I go
and he just didn't get up and I thought
he was dead. He goes, sometimes
they die. And walks away.
Dead serious. Dead serious.
Yeah. He was training troops.
Old School. Yeah. He didn't care at
all and I was like, but wait a minute.
They died. I'm them. I'm, hey man.
I got for sure disposable. I wasn't the
best for sure. Somebody get a fuck me.
I never got head kicked, but I saw people
that I was close to get head kicked in.
Ever get killed in tournaments.
Just Tko.
Tko boxing match and kickboxing match
where they stopped. You got rock,
then he came in and stopped it.
Yeah. I got rock with a left hook.
I got my legs just shut off point.
Where does that,
it's the weirdest feeling of all time.
What people think is that like it hurts.
No liver shot hurts.
Like if you get kicked to the liver or
punched in the liver and your whole body
will die and your legs kind of give out,
that hurts.
But this is a weird thing
about getting hit on the chin.
It's like everything just
goes surreal feeling. Yeah.
Just stops working and
let my body would get hot.
It's a weird word. The worst man. What
is it like to get completely flatlined?
Um, it, it's nothing because you
don't, you don't feel anything. Right.
So you don't feel anything. You don't,
when you come out of it. What's your,
what's your most recent memory?
Not much. Everything's a little,
a little like fuzzy.
And then someone tells you what happened
and then you remember certain parts of
the fight. Like God, I remember doing
that and that and then what happened?
You know what I'm saying? Like you have
to piece it, like puzzle it together.
This is one. And then you get
in the back, cause there's,
there's two type of people that when
you get concussed or flatline in my
experiences, you react to it two
ways. One, you get really emotional,
like heartbroken, sat like super,
Super Sad. The other gets really,
really upset, like mad
super mad. And I, I,
I've always seen those
two opposites new thing.
It is this from concussed or is this
from the emotions of losing and realizing
you lost after it's all over?
I think it's a combination of both.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
But this is one of the reasons why I want
to bring this up is because everybody
always wants to talk about
the power of belief, you know,
and how important the power of belief
is. And it's super important. You know,
instead it's a big factor.
And Connor success is this like
insane belief he has in himself.
But even with the power of belief at
10 you still have to deal with the
limitations to the body.
Correct.
And you still have to deal with like
what is the reality of getting hit on the
chin? Correct. But that,
that self belief that Connor has got him
into the biggest fight in combat sports
history on her feet and had a
little bit of doubt. We're not here.
You're 100% you're talking about them.
I know. So it's a fine line say ah,
self belief only goes so
far, man. Even myself,
I myself belief was so high
private match my skills,
but I was so confident I could
beat anyone in the world.
I beat a lot of guys that probably had
no business beating or just getting
through the beat cro cop. He's a legend
and you beat him by knockout. Yeah,
but like get getting
through golden gloves. Man.
I thought I was the next Mike
Tyson. I brought, probably not,
but I beat most of those
guys. Just stuff. Sure. Whale.
But I believed in my heart of hearts I
was going to be the best of all time. No,
you were a competitor.
And there's some people that have
a hard time with the big moment.
Conor obviously shines in the big moment,
but at the end of the day,
even with that insane belief,
you get to see his physical limitations.
But what you got to see though is, well,
you got to see a lot in that fight,
but you don't know what's going
to happen until they do it.
That's why I didn't fight.
So he has this amazing, uh,
belief in himself and he had a
really interesting style man,
that whole thing where he was doing
like putting his hands out there and,
and pap pap pap and them.
Yeah.
And then throwing off offspeed
punches and then drop out.
And his ankles were so good,
so good and and so exaggerated in
big huge get Floyd's back and Floyd.
Scary, smart. He wouldn't turn into
him. They give him more of an angle.
He just cover up because you had
the ref was going to stop it.
The real MVP of that fight, granted,
you know Conor and Floyd, that Raf, oh,
I read them fine. You're the
real MVP. Panted he came,
his opening dialogue with the hell was
that he was just staring at Mcgregor like
now we don't want to know that that
gay Raslan in just like students.
I don't think he said that.
I think I thought he was way over the top.
I wanted the fight to start,
so I thought he was over the top
because I wanted to fight. Come on,
let's go with this fucking national
anthem. Do you do that in a locked room?
But I just thought it was off to the
wrong foot, but I think he, granted,
I don't think Connor was going to win
that fight as it went on. However he,
the Connor did have an advantage
if they went in tight heat,
even let it get there yet
grappling under hooks. What,
and that was where Conor
was going to get his rest.
He didn't have that opportunity as soon
as they got to that ref separated. Yeah,
it was good. He was gonna let him fight
it. Yeah, he was in London fight though.
He was the perfect rest.
However,
I think Connor thought you'd be able to
get his rest in those moments and just
never was capable of doing
it cause the ref would,
I think he got more tired than he ever
thought it was going to or down to.
Also the efficiency of Floyd.
Here's what I did.
I watched it live from the third round
on. I got offstage, Washington DC,
the first two I ran upstate.
I did last yesterday.
I watched it yesterday when I
get home, but I flew home. Um,
our mayor flew upstairs.
It was that they had it on paper
view in the upstairs green rooms.
So we ran upstairs type
move. Yeah, it was,
but I caught on the third round and yell
and Ian Edwards, I'm like, I'm like,
how's it going? He goes, the fights.
Great. This is a great fight.
So I got in there like writing it.
I didn't want to give,
this is people waiting in line a
long time. The show started late.
People bought tickets months in advance
and I'm like, I'm not cut my show short.
Yeah,
I'm going to do the full show and then
I'm gonna thank everybody good night and
then watch the fight for a better person.
So I ran upstairs and uh,
I got in the third round
so I didn't see all the,
the speech until I heard about
it afterwards so that I heard it.
I tried to watch from the time
they were both walking out,
but the national and um,
stop.
I love America.
I'm not mad at Demi Lovato.
She can sing when ever
she would go to a concert.
It's an American flag. It's on
my phone. Okay. I love America.
Love it. I'm a big proponent
in the best aspects of America,
but to see, I like the rocket's
red glare and the bumps.
I couldn't get enough. I
was standing ovation. Bravo.
She's a beautiful singer. No doubt in her
shit from a teleprompter though. Well,
it's probably a good move. You don't want
to fuck it up. Like who fucked it up?
Miley Cyrus and she fucked it up.
There's been some people that fucking,
somebody forgot the words. Somebody
fucked, fucked up the words. Oh,
Christina Aguilera. That's who it was
that her, that was Christina when she was,
she was going through a tough time,
which got a little heavy back then.
Remember that? Yeah. She got
heavy. Christina, like unsexy,
thick. Like she got a little
over the line to like,
what's going on to too many supersizes.
It's not just that like when
someone gets that big that quick,
you start thinking about depression. You
know that wasn't Roseanne Barr. Well,
you know what she did though?
That was back in the day when
Roseanne was on top of the world.
She grabbed a pussy and spit,
which is hilarious. Yeah.
She's so sad.
As a savage of savages and people got
Super Mad at her and this was pre social
media, but, but click on
the youtube link to that.
Find out what or if it says there,
when Roseanne did it,
[inaudible] year was 1990 and nine Diego.
Yeah.
See totally before the Internet spits
on the ground right before. Why not?
She's an animal. She's an adult.
She's an animal. I love her.
You know Whitney is like executive
producing her new show. That makes sense.
Totally makes sense.
Yeah. And Whitney's like,
she's a great joke writer to phenomenal
writer and probably, I mean I got a fee.
I don't, I don't remember really
talking to her too much about Roseanne.
Maybe we did. I look at that. She
grabbed her pussy. It's Spanish traces.
I maintained she one of the top most
important comedians of all time after I
said that to her when she was here,
I said,
you changed the face of women's comedy.
She did.
She changed the face of women's College.
She got her start in Denver son. Yes,
she did. Comedy works, comedy works.
She's a beast with kids at all.
Those kids graduated and a dad moving
out hit the whole deal and the animal
fucking animal. I like her. Yeah. Oh,
we're talking about they're
doing a show together. But I got,
what I was going to say is that I gotta
think that Whitney must think about it
the same way most of most of the
comics do. She's super respected.
Rosanna mean super respect.
That's a big job for Whitney.
Fuck yeah, that's huge.
That has a potential,
especially right now, like
what the Hell is on TV? I
agree. You know, you got Kevin.
James has a sitcom name and others
had come. Ready, go. I got nothing.
I got nothing. Goldberg's I'll tell
you what. I did start watching.
I started watching Ozark. Oh my God. It's
good. Those are, what was arc on Netflix?
Oh, Justin Bateman chasing,
chasing, chasing baby.
He gets involved with the cartel. Yep.
Seen it. I just saw the dude, dude,
I'll hold up. I'm on season four of game
of Thrones balls deep and who don't,
I cannot get the Dragon Tattoo. And I
was talking all that stay offline. Uh,
people try to send me spoilers. Ain't
happening son. I don't even look at them.
Yeah, you gotta be an engine.
Just the biggest Khaleesi
fan. I will just wait. Oh,
I can't wait. The queen of
dragons. Just wait. Those dragons.
John's know this. I know I'm going to
say anything but this season finale,
just Jesus Christ and then I see people
online where the g game of Thrones lost
its way. I'm like, how about you
fuck off. How about you, him haters.
Everyone's going to hate on
anything, man. I'll tell you what.
The white walkers though, I'm on season
three. Them graphics were tough on,
see it looked like a tare out there.
That's like white things.
Get to season seven I saw can fund. I
saw one. They look like some super beast.
Oh yeah.
They've got that wired.
They know how to do it at an ice
wall and the game is that real?
There's like a shut the fuck up.
It's like the flat earth, right?
Let me start there. The same thing
or it's not the same across the wall.
I mean, I think it's in
the north. In the north.
You've got to keep a war. How good
is it? It's fucking phenomenal.
I'm so happy I was.
I'm telling you I could not sleep.
I was so happy that King Joffrey died.
That little bitch. Spoiler alert. Hey Bro,
they're on season seven,
five years. Three alert.
People will get mad.
How dare you Shab I'm on season one.
If it's more than three years old,
I'm allowed to talk about it for sure.
People get mad if you talk about something
that happened 10 years ago though.
They get mad like if they haven't seen it,
it's like you're not supposed
to discuss things. Hey Bro.
How to, yeah. Yeah. I love it though.
I'm obsessed with game of Thrones.
All I watch right now,
it's the best show of all time.
I think the writing,
but I'll say that about other shows to
me to say that I get excited. Me Too.
I'll throw that out no matter what. If
I get enthusiastic, don't hold me to it.
I'm not some fucking ranking committee.
You know what I mean? He's like
the UFC ranking. You know
what? We're like to use rings.
We just throw up whatever you want.
However I feel I'm just going to do that.
All right.
Give it to us number one next
week. I don't know. We'll see.
I think Max Kellerman
is walking around today.
How many people are fucking with him?
I saw him this morning.
Hundred Mcgregor will not land
a single punch. Meanwhile,
he landed more punches
on Floyd Mayweather.
An any boxer ever than many Pacquiao and
Miguel Cotto. Yeah. And then people go,
oh, this is a fricking
Max is a debate. Oh,
well that's because Floyd led
them. That was his style. Hey man,
let's give Connor sub credit some credit.
His pace was so high.
I think cottage pace was so high and he
thought it was me landing more shots.
He just wore himself out.
He's a little bit of that.
I think there's a little
bit of an efficiency issue
that you know, John, Donna,
her go to John Donahoe, his
Instagram page, please. John Donner,
who's, um, you know,
one of the best grapplers you to
master World Jujitsu mastermind.
He's also a brilliant guy. He's like
Elon Musk of Jujitsu, basically cap,
super smart, innovative
guy. But on top of that,
he wrote an assessment of how he
thinks the fight's going to play out.
And it was to at t spot on
about the cardio. Is that um,
Donna her said that he was gonna um, stop
him sometime, uh, after the fifth round.
What does it say? Yeah. Tonight is
the biggest night BP. BP. Oh Man.
It's the way to long John. Well, he does
that. He's just too small. Well, it's hey,
but create a blog though,
huh? You know? Yeah.
I mean basically he said here I consider
a fine a victory for Mr Mcgregor if he
survived 12 rounds. Yeah. See,
scroll up a little bit and he'll explain
how he said that it usually works. Yeah.
Here it goes. They are quite
competitive. The first three to four
rounds and he surprisingly,
well then around the fifth round,
the elite boxer begins to figure out
the unorthodox were awkward movement and
begins to employ ring craft tactics,
attire,
the MMA athlete by making more harder
than he is making mispunches et cetera.
Around the eighth round.
A very noticeable shift occurs
where the elite boxer takes over.
I expect a similar pattern tonight though.
Probably taking less time given the
incredible skill lever, Mr Mayweather.
But it was the exact thing
around the eighth round May,
whether it was clearly shaken
over the ninth round May,
whether it was getting was fucking
Connor off was teeing off on Connor and I
actually texted to my friend in
between rounds. I'm like, he's done.
They're going to stop. I gotta stop last
round. They threatened to go to the,
to the back to do some for
showtime. I was like, it's over.
They wouldn't let you know. They did.
That made you go, you gotta go back.
You miss some of it. Well, I
didn't want to see it really.
I knew it was over. Yeah.
So then, but then they put me
Kate side. I was, wait, weren't,
you didn't want to see it? Uh, not
really. I knew what was happening. I just,
I dunno. I Dunno. How could
you not want to see it?
I knew what I was going to happen. I
then she would watch rocky movies, Bro.
I wish, man, but I'm glad they stopped
it early. I wasn't mad at the stoppage.
I wasn't either.
I wasn't mad cause for number of reasons,
but he has a lot more fight left in
and there's no, we got it. You got it.
Connor did well.
He wants some rounds.
He's going to get fucked up in
the next round if he made it.
If he made into 11th Floyd Mayweather
was going to fuck him up. Correct.
Like real bad. He was gas in. But you're
Connor and even Floyd afterwards he goes,
Floyd, they go, what was the
most surprising thing about
this fight? And he goes,
collars, box and skills. Honestly, I
thought I'd be able to take over early,
but I wasn't able to because
of his boxing skills. He goes,
I wasn't surprised by his
power. There wasn't much power
there, which is, you know,
whatever. He ate that upper flow
straight up flush up or kept from Connor.
But Conor did not seem like he was
putting a lot of power in its punches.
It looks like he was trying
to be like real active,
but then also he was like kind of winging
them too while he was hitting him with
some weird stuff like this. And he'd
even did a bunch of Hammerfest and stuff.
Did you know for every
illegal shot that he,
if he got [inaudible] for $10
million out of his purse, 10 Mil.
So when everyone's like,
how do you know he's just not going to
throw a knee or an elbow, like a savage,
like,
well,
there's 10 million reasons why I get mail
hairdresser that that was the media I
dealt with a media row. All how, you know,
he's just not going to
throw a knee and flip out.
How do you know Brendon? How do you
know he's not going to need him? Right.
And then
people saw it and I'd have
to go from having now,
even now, isn't it funny that
there's no idea as a gay voice,
like if you do that voice, everyone
knows it's a game. There's not a lesbian.
There's, well, there's really
not a butch lesbian. Oh,
that seems to be a female truck
driver that loves Dick Smokes.
Marlboro is every hour. Leroy's it doesn't
necessarily mean she's a lesbian. Yeah.
Large March. March, March,
March. Yes. Greg Roberts
large.
That's what I was Sturge bars.
Sencha I was terrified. A
large march. You really,
the big blue balls poke out
dude.
Peewee's big adventure, right?
First one. First one yet.
God Damn. If she was scary.
Great movie. Yeah, man.
Oh,
we can hear it.
He's all freaked out and when
they finally pulled the drivers,
Johnny,
I love that movie.
I'm so glad you got that reference dude.
Peewee's big adventure was one of
my favorite movies when I was a kid.
I went with my high school girlfriend.
We went and we were fucking crying.
We just couldn't believe how hard we
were laughing. It was so good, man.
It was so silly. Then the next one after
that was a big Top, big top pee. Wee pig
is a little pig.
That was his best friend.
Feed them sandwiches and shit while
he's trying to get with that girl.
Is he silly fucking movie? If you've
never seen that movie and you smoke weed,
you are in luck. Large March. Just
fire one up. Makes a cameo though.
She's not there for long. Long enough.
It'd be nice. We're still talking to
that movie came out in like 84 right?
that's when the show came out
because I was born in 83 pull it up,
pull it up because I was in high school,
say early nineties man,
my mom had the VHS.
It's all we'd watch.
I graduated high school in
[inaudible] 85 and this is, uh,
my high school girlfriend and I went to
see it. Mm. Maybe she was in high school.
Whoa. Oh Damn. Joe Rogan.
1985 c Sun.
I was,
I 100% remember being in high
school and she was in high school.
We were both in school and we went
to see it. Wow. Powerful Giotto.
His bike was sick. Was that was before
the TV show or, I don't know, man.
I think the TV show was out
before that. A kid show, I guess.
I mean the kids that a HBO special. Oh
yeah. That was later. That was later.
I think he does that show up like
straight up ABC though. Remember?
I would watch it in the mornings.
Why? I was saying I was,
I thought it was after that he was house
and then he got caught like jacking off
to the theater.
Right.
That was actually after all that he got
caught Jackin off after he stopped doing
the TV show.
Really?
I thought it was like in the middle
of the nineties I was like 90 rolling.
How's this crew going to take an l? Just
cause he jacked off in a movie theater.
Yeah. That was back in the
day where we already had VHS.
Like if you jacked off and
it was in a movie theater,
that was the only way to jack off.
Everybody's like, Eh, we understand. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Give the guy a break.
But if you jack off in a movie theater
when we have VHS, well you're a pervert.
91 damn arrested for masturbating and an
adult theater in [inaudible] 91 that's
so crazy. What was the movie?
Sarasota. Florida is the problem.
They had a fucking thing in Sarasota
and how do they know that he really did
jack off. He was right. Really? We're
turning up the heat and tiger shark.
Nancy nurse was another one.
Then he went to see, uh Oh, okay,
well that's what people do in those days.
He was only 38 at the time.
38 he's the most shot out. 38 year
old ever seen. Look at that picture.
This picture,
it looks like it's like, I like the
blogger at the set of hair on him too.
It looks like a blogger.
Jack's off the guys in a band.
He could totally be like a bass player.
Was He smart? Is he just loaded or what?
Because he was a big deal when I was a
kid. Dad Merchandise and everything man.
Well,
he took a big hit from this.
I think if it happened today
it would be no big deal.
But also part of the problem was that he
was like a childhood idol thing because
you know his show was a kid show even
though it was kind of adult themed in a
lot of a way. A lot of ways.
So word of the day. Yeah.
See the HBO Cable Television Show
popularized by [inaudible] in 1982.
Yeah.
He would look up girls skirts with the
aid of mirror as attached to his shoes.
He was like, your regional
character. He's a creep. Why QE?
We taught kids how to do that.
Basically. That's fucked up.
But everybody already knew back then.
Start a fire with a match. Yeah.
It's all good,
man.
Do you know what I think people get
figured out how to put a fucking mirror on
your shoe. That was an old
movies man. But then he just, uh,
he just shot a show for Netflix.
Did it like they made a movie like
periods back, right? Yup. Yup. Wow.
That's a long hiatus. They took them
that long to recover. You know what?
That little too late. You
know, like way too late.
That's like entourage came with that
movie like 10 years after the finale.
Come on, man. Why they do that? It'd
take a long time to make the movie.
I don't know. Personalities didn't
show. We do really well though.
I don't think so. The entourage movie
rotten tomatoes gives it like a zero
bad but didn't do as good as they
needed it to or did not do well.
The critics destroyed that thing. It
was just too late. Men yet turtle.
He's 50 on that bitch.
It's like sex and the city can go back
today and chicks were flocked to it
weren't people piss it a six and the
city movie, they might have been,
well you don't like cause
they can do it with them.
They go through like menopause and
shit the name right, right, right.
Like the young chicks anymore chasing
Dick. Well you know it was weird.
It was like that one character of
the, what's her name? Samantha? Yeah,
the slutty character.
Straight up whore. Yeah.
It gave like a lot of women
like they can go. Yeah,
she could do it and I love her.
Why can't I do it?
That's why everyone can relate to
that shit. Like was the smart one.
There's one that career driven was the
whore and you had one of your friends was
one of them I feel like. But they loved
their horror friend. Yeah. So it was like,
it gave her it like it was
opposite of slut shaming.
Be Yourself. Let your freak
flag fly. Be like, Samantha,
everybody's not Samantha,
but Samantha's not everybody like B or
whoever the fuck you are. Who are you?
If you're,
if you're a super freak and you're
around a bunch of squares and then he was
holding it back, get some
strange deck. I'll give you this,
that check. So once it go, just drink a
couple of cosmopolitans. Throw some guy.
You're fucking kidding. Go. Let's
go. Yeah man. What's wrong with that?
So let's rock songs. Yeah. As long as
it's not your daughter, you're good. Yeah.
Well it's also, as long as you
don't run into the wrong dude,
that would be the big
fear of being a woman,
running into some fucking scary guy,
sending bad murderers,
rapists,
terrible person.
Like you're way more likely to
run into that person as a woman,
then you are sure. Male predators,
predators drank on Samantha, dropping,
shitting your drinks, you know,
dropping shit into drinks.
That's so rampant. If I was a
girl, I would be terrified of that.
I've met so many people that have told
me stories about a guy drug in them or
drug and one of their friends or
drug drugging someone they know.
I thought it was like an old school thing,
but still goes on kind of a friend.
She told me, yeah, she was out at the
club and she goes, and then I woke up.
Luckily nothing happened, but I woke
up no memory of what happened before.
I'm like, yeah man in La, like that's
still happening. She's like, yeah,
100% why the fuck would you take a drink
from a dude though? Like you should be.
You know what I'm saying? Well, it should
be like friendly people. Like, Hey,
would you like a beer? Yeah, sure.
Give you a beer. It should be.
That's how it should be. Should
be. I mean, I, ideal circumstances,
she should be able to, but there's just
too many creeps. The world we live in.
Like what'd you tell your daughters
when they're old enough? Like, Hey,
do not take a drink unless you're,
you know what I'm saying? Of course.
That's what the world we live
in. You can't just, it's not,
it's not worth the risk.
I mean,
hopefully you're going to run into only
nice people who give you a drink and
they just want to have some drinks
with friends and have some laughs.
Have you ever heard of girls Roofie to
dude? Never, but I'm sure it's happened.
I did.
Here we will.
You always heard that story about like
the fake urban myth about the Russian
girl who,
uh,
gets you drank and it takes you back to
your own kidney and then you wake up.
Yeah. Such a bag of ice. You wake up with
a bag of ice on your side and stitches.
It tells you to get to
a hospital immediately.
Like what is that an urban legend
could be. I mean, when never happened.
That's brings up Jamie's point early
today before the podcast that we need a
more reliable Snopes.
Yeah.
Not that Snopes is a reliable cause
apparently it's pretty, pretty reliable,
but nobody is what the problem is.
Nobody wants to listen to Snopes anymore
because it turned out that the dude who
rants Snopes is a freak and like one of
the chicks that is like his number one
employee was a woman who was an escort
until like 2015 and now she's married to
him and he's just a freak.
He's just partying all the time,
having a good old time. But why is
that so bad? Like why does that affect,
and also they have a left lane left
wing bias that a lot of people,
a lot of people think they have
a left wing bias at least. Yeah,
I guess sort of maybe,
but I mean if they're just relaying facts
you can rely on them I think for the
most part. But that's not
enough. Who can you rely on?
Like even on the New York
Times you post on Instagram,
do you see they changed their headache,
they changed it, they changed it.
I went out of my way. I
was like, this is crazy.
I read the New York Times basically
every day. It should be me too.
It should be pretty reliable. I have it
on my app, on my phone, my phone. Yeah.
That's where I go in the morning.
Yeah. I get notifications from them.
Take time to anything happens in the news.
So I read tons of articles
from the New York Times.
Do you see the guy I looked up that
explains to them? No, I didn't.
Wanna I didn't wanna like get personal.
No,
I just wanted to see what was going on.
It just a giant fuck up.
You can't do that. He's also not a
sports writer. He writes more about race.
He's a young guy, you know.
I doubt it. Flight. Yeah.
He Goes New York Times
writer for race. Why? Yeah.
That seems like it would be within your
best interest to keep things fucked up,
you know? I'm not saying maybe
that's why he's here. You know,
like who the hell maybe. I mean, look you,
all you had to know was say what
happened is that after, uh, you know,
just say Floyd Maguire,
Mcgregor,
Floyd Mayweather out classes
and stops Conor McGregor,
it stops and exhausted Conor McGregor
and the 10th round. That's what happened.
He was exhausted.
And he got tagged over and over again,
and Floyd was teeing off on him and his
brilliant performances that really paint
the f the fight though I, I dunno if
I'll put it in the hallway for sure.
Use your words better. And the
headline, you can't say completely,
his face was completely bloodied
and he always went way ropes.
Bidell things are not true.
I don't think you actually watched it.
Reading the headline.
He probably looked at the maybe photos
or someone else's narrative of the fight
photos. Even the of the
bloody, well, you know,
I guess a photo of Connor outside the
ring and Willie's live outside the ring
for God's sakes. I saved the photo man.
Like here's no, no one's face was bloody.
There was no bloody
period. I mean, it just,
it just wasn't bloody like
you could see his face.
Like I got a photo of the
actual stoppage itself, Bro.
At the moment the stoppage happened.
He was a, I mean, you know,
you have like a little bit of two best
under his left eye. There was an affair.
No blood. Yeah. He had a mouse from the
right hand land. Again, up. No blood.
Neither guy was. Yeah, the, you don't see
the mouse there. You see his right cheek.
It's under his, let's just read
his eyes were rolling a little bit.
Did you hear 100 million
illegal streaming downloads?
What? 100 million illegal
streams. Holy Shit.
How much revenue they lose.
How about this?
How crazy is this Floyd to warm up in
the back? Someone from his team goes,
Yo Floyd, the systems in California,
Florida down. He goes, God, damn,
those are huge markets here. I'm going
to delay till they figure it out.
That's how conscious this mother before
this huge fight. That's good. He goes,
I'm going to wait.
I'm going to wait and it's worth
millions and millions of John Saying,
how brilliant is he?
That was my takeaway with working with
showtime and get so close to Floyd and
doing all this stuff.
He's
so God damn brilliant man. Like
I had preconceived notions. I am.
He's a good boxer.
Outbid good of a businessman.
How involved is he known and he doesn't
let anything go on touch without
overseeing everything. Both
everything. He's brilliant.
He's brilliant as a producer or as a
promoter and he's brilliant as a fighter.
Brilliant. Then they asked him about, uh,
so I was in the fighters meetings and
they have all the serious showtime guys
there and were miked up and all, all
access crew and Floyd's grew and they go,
hey, be careful. Cause last
time we did this with Floyd,
he didn't really know the guys and he
kicked him out in front of everyone was
super embarrassing. So
I'm like, oh that sucks.
Some of my suits sitting there and
everyone's so serious. I'm like,
this is so serious, so stuffy in
here. So the guy goes, Jim Gray,
Tim gray goes, hey, up Floyd. They're
like writing the notes down to send there,
like staring down. And
they go, uh, you know,
you always walk out with like an
entourage usually for your fights.
There's usually some big
celebrity or something like that.
Who's it going to be this time?
And I know previously you had beef
with Justin Bieber, so I was like,
well better now than never. I just
went out of turn, not the beads,
the beads
and the FOI laugh Floyd,
he's talking dead to that.
Jim Gray, his glasses on.
He takes the glasses off and goes,
damn dog.
I'm trying to be positive up in here.
We're trying to be positive. And I go,
I start laughing.
I know all the same.
Him walking out with you man,
what's wrong with that?
He started laughing after that.
Everyone was literally like on pins and
needles and I was like, come on man.
So bebes is all about Church
now, Huh? Is that the thing?
Like he unfollowed Floyd and
Floyd got mad at him. Yeah.
And that that guy can unfollow your boy.
CanNot follow your boy ever and that
guy never unfollow you ever bro.
If we do then there's some
serious not happening for me.
Where there clap back at Justin
Bieber to try and be positive.
He's just a pop star. Floyd says, well,
it's got to a point which is just a pop
star who is probably the biggest pop
store on the planet.
He canceled his tour like he stopped
his tour because of this Jesus thing,
that pretty sky. I know that guy
in the Bible study with a guy.
I've been to dinner with that guy.
He's an interesting dude.
If you're both demon Jesus, he's your
guy. Keep talking. Tell me more. I don't,
I don't want to be out. I don't
wanna I don't want no bad juju on me.
I don't want to be the golden
snitch for pop stars. I,
I don't know what's going on there.
There were saying that Justin Bieber
already made $93 million this year before
he cancelled the tour. How fucking nuts
is that? They kid is balling so hard.
Even him and then I think, yes, I'm do
with Kyrie Irving too. And Kyrie was like,
yeah, I want out of Cleveland. Like this
motherfucker has some power. He's like,
Jesus wants you to play for Boston.
You know that, right? Right.
So what is he doing to them? Trying
to get them to, well look, look,
maybe he's doing something. Maybe
I'm looking at the wrong way. Right.
So if he has a positive influence on
them, maybe saying, man, you're, you're,
you're so involved in show business
and some of them you got to think about
living and life taking a moment. Not
only that, like, here's the thing man,
once you make $93 million, it's
basically over. I've changes button,
but I'm saying it's over.
Just relax. It's over.
You put that fucking money in the bank.
You don't have to work
anymore so I can't work. Yeah.
All the work you do from here on out
is gravy. This is what you do now.
You do what you want to do.
Do you want to go out and do a bunch of
concerts in front of these people or are
you doing too much? Because
if you're working, like if
you, if you had to go and,
uh, do theaters my now you've
been doing a lot of stand up.
If you had to do theaters Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday, every week,
flying everywhere. Oh, that'd be, we're
so tired. You just see, I'd be like,
Amanda Bynes you just see my hair is
all fucked up. I'd be going crazy.
I'd be like Katt Williams.
I engineered how I do like this.
Latin might thi this is the first tour
that I ever named the strange times tour.
The first time I ever sold a
bunch of tickets in advance,
like the smart marketing,
but I engineered that like when
I'm doing these like fly to places,
I'm off for awhile.
That's you'll be gone to do that.
You have to do with that way and Bieber
has the power to kill 100% he just
canceled everything. You just canceled
everything west of the same thing.
What Kanye West did after they
checked him into the loony Bin,
which he was going crazy. They said
he would do that concert, come home.
He had all this work yet to do with the
DDAS and clothing and they just said
he's working nonstop and a
small glimpse of, of, you know,
show business and stand up and
all this stuff. It. I mean,
I can see how being on a tour that
long during go fucking batshit crazy.
I can see a little bit like when I saw
it. Oh, I Batman. That's crazy. Well,
you know what a big factor for me is a
big factor for me is when I'm at home,
I'm going to sleep for eight
hours and I have a schedule. Yes.
In terms of like my runs your
routine by lifts, you know,
whatever workout I'm doing,
whatever kind of thing I'm doing,
I know where I can train.
I know the schools I could train out,
I know the gyms I could train up and
I know what to do. That keeps me sane.
Like having those, like I can work
out on the road and it's good.
It's definitely better than nothing,
but it's not the same.
I've liked being able to have this normal,
like it keeps my energy up
and it keeps my anxiety down.
Like all those things get bounced out.
When I,
when I'm at my normal workout routine,
when I go on the road,
I'm doing three days in a row.
It's hard because I don't want to work
out too hard cause I don't want to be
tired for two shows. Yeah, I've
got two big big ass theater shows,
but I can't imagine those guys who
do five nights, so they're flying in.
So I did two this week, two shows
this weekend. So I flew in three days.
I took three flights. He said, you know,
that's crazy. Crazy. But that's nothing.
It's still under those guys
that do it five days a week,
six days. Well the, well,
even still on private jets, it's still
exhausting. Exhausted. The same thing.
Same thing.
I mean you don't have to,
it goes more on your schedule I guess
if you're flying everywhere for the
private jet, but it's still fucking
exhaust. Still a beast, man. Yeah.
So I get a little, people will go, you
poor baby. I know. Poor oh 93
million. I'm like, theory have money.
So it's not that they're already
set there, it's already gravy.
But without back to the
Bieber Floyd thing again,
I had preconceived notions
of Floyd Mayweather before
I met him, been around him,
sodas,
this religious guy,
he thinks oh Floyd's just about
hoes and cars and stuff like that.
That's all that I guess what he's more,
there's more layers to that.
So for you to judge them based off
social media, say Bieber quit falling,
quit hanging out with him cause he's
just about that. No you don't know shit.
You're judging that guy cause he's
not going to church every Sunday.
You know what I'm saying? Like you're,
you're judging him based off Instagram,
which isn't fair to do you. I think he's
saying like, I dunno what he's saying,
but I would imagine if someone tells you
to stop following somebody that they're
saying there, that person's
a bad influence. Right.
Which isn't fair to say
because Floyd doesn't drink,
has crazy work ethic overseas
bases, showtime sports. Gee,
you know what I'm saying? Like he's
healthy. He doesn't it. It's girls Bro.
Strip clubs.
You don't strip club brought
some of the women he hangs out with.
I had never seen anything like that.
But that's what 15 oh get you. I
mean, jaw dropping shit. Hundreds
and they just look at me like a bag of
shit and he's Gucci shoes. Gucci shoes.
Oh, I get it. Not 15 old girl.
Hundreds of millions of dollars that all
access where they showed that fucking
stupid watch. They bought them that
Hubo Hubo do. I'd met with the guy from,
who will tell me all about it.
Watches so gross nuts.
It's so stupid looking crystal.
One Point two 8 million. No,
it was $500,000 I think they made
another one for 1.2 they made them three.
It's crazy to watch. It's all crystal
like the outside of it is all crystal.
That's an ad. It's so stupid. Look and it
looks like a cheap watch. Yeah, I agree.
Not My style. I do love who blow though.
Shadow. Yeah. They make great watches it,
but that thing, the La Ferrari, isn't
that what it's called? Yeah. Yeah.
There you go. It looks he rose.
Did you see the money belt? Yes.
They handed me that thing.
This is real.
It was kind of small and that I get
it smelt like they just killed that
alligator on the spot. It smelt
like Hummus and allocated.
It smelled like shit,
but then it's just like gold all
over it. I was like, oh my God.
In diamonds and shit and rubies.
Do you know who made that poop?
Floyd Mayweather's team.
Did they see a gift to him because they
thought for sure he's going to win that
like yeah, here's this crazy
money fight belt for 1.2 million.
We designed ourselves.
Here you go Floyd. Wow.
Type one point $2 million for
that ugly belt. I was all,
I was all up on that thing. Well tell
me about this then. Are those red?
Is the red all, what are
those, those gems? Are they,
what is the red stuff like in the flags?
All the flags.
Those are just like colors. Those
aren't real. That's not real,
but the diamonds and all that and gold,
all that through most of
is about of all time. Damn.
The thing was sweet dope booking.
Yeah.
It was all fun to like 600 Sapphire's,
160 emeralds, 3000 diamond, sorry,
thousand 360 diamonds and weighs
three pounds of 24 karat gold.
That thing was tiny though.
Pounds of gold that's holding.
It was like a little belt. It wasn't like
the big ass belt. It looks normal sized.
Are they all like that?
Maybe I'm just fucking Shaquille O'Neal,
but if you look at a picture with me,
it looks small checks when they're
holding it up, click on this link. Small.
How weird are the fucking ring car?
Girls do boxing.
They stand around behind everything and
smile from fucking roll the Stepford
wives for our,
that's all they do is pose.
Would that big smile. It's so odd. It's
like they don't express any personality.
They don't do anything other than stand
there and have that same with miles up
there and shit. What do you want him
to do? Yeah, but they're not like,
like looking at each other and talking
about like you have this chance smile.
They're like those English soldiers,
they star and I'll tell you what,
corona does it right. It's what
they're like. Corona does it right.
I'm not mad at any of them.
There was no slump busters
or all of them were tents.
All were stone cold said.
All were shaped stone cold.
Ted's dad smiling. Yeah. And
just not moving like robots
and one hand on the hip.
I feel like they hit him, hit him.
They don't bitch is where the line,
they just dropped that belt in their head,
dude. How about just yet? That it Dick,
how US clunk cop out. I'm uh, doing, uh,
before the Wayne's I'm doing a pretty
fight show and Floyd Mayweather.
Seniors standing to my right gun.
You don't know shit.
You don't know what the hell are you
talking about? Shop? You don't know shit.
And I'm like trying to get through it,
not pay attention to them
that stop playing, Bro. What
are you doing? Come on man.
What are you doing?
I'm selling the fight and clicking.
I'm putting money in your son's pocket,
man.
You need someone up here to talk about
it. What are you doing? It just cause I,
you know, when you're talking about
like Jesus Christ, man, relax. Yeah,
he's a smooth talker.
That senior. Yeah. Yeah.
Real smooth. It's like, yeah.
I imagine if you're Floyd and you
like literally see your future,
if you keep getting hit in the head like
right in front of me. Yeah. Heavy stuff.
I mean that's gotta be one of the reasons
why he's so brilliant defensively.
Not just cause he learned from his dad.
He learned from Roger Mayweather and all
the people in the gym that he trained
with,
but also he sees the effects of come
Shannon punishment and his brother or his
uncle rather as well. Yeah. Brought
Germaine. Whether there's, you know,
he's not doing well, you
know, none of them are doing
great man. We're doing great.
He's perfect though. 40 years
old, speak perfect, sharp,
knows everything about it and everything
and they thought that Javante Davis,
oh I didn't see you were doing it.
You saw yesterday,
he's a kid who they thought was going to
be the next paper you king and you can
tell athlete and he's just like,
he's missing a few things. He goes,
because you just can't be 30 and old
with 30 knockouts and expect to be a mega
star. You have to have everything he's
like, so he has to work on so much more.
I don't know. And he's
130 pounds. It's tough.
His weight, he missed weight, but he took
the fine short notice. He missed weight,
had a horrible fight short notice,
I want to say took it on to cause that I
think Sean Porter supposed to fight and
then he backed out. So then they booked
this dude. He's fun to watch though.
He has the most intense tattoo I've ever
seen. What is it? It's done. It's for him.
He's from like the straight hood of
uh, Baltimore. And as he's talking,
I looked down at the stir up people's
tattoos and it was a apartment building.
Brick building on fire in front of
apartment building is a mass burglar.
Black burglar would like the old school
rubber mask on with a bag of money and
the gun. Why? Yeah, I was like,
shout out to that terrible tattoo.
Jesus. He had a bad fight though.
And that was kind of his, you know,
his platform to do something, but I don't
see him being the next like big thing.
Yeah. He can tell Floyd too is
like, mm hmm. Before he's like,
this is the next up and coming guy.
He's a nice Floyd Mayweather and now I'm
like, he's, he's the next 40 million.
He's like, hmm. Not really. No.
He had a rough fight too.
Yeah, it was a rough fight.
He clipped that dude behind the ear or
behind the head, but that's just like,
we're punches land where people duck
is sometimes shit happens and you know,
the guy was complaining about it.
He went down.
I'll tell you what was
cool is after the fight,
I'm in the back and I see American,
Terrence Crawford and uh,
Andre Berto.
And so I go to talk them and they were
all like super complimentary of Conor
Mcgregor. Like, dude, he getting box, man.
I'm like, ride like, what'd you think?
You're just going to go in there, look
like an asshole like Bart Simpson and fly.
I was like this, like, what'd
you expect to happen? Like,
we just didn't expect
him to get any rounds.
We thought it was just gonna be out
class. I'm like, Nah man, he looked,
he has tremendous belief in himself and
he had a weird style that that's strange
style of offspeed punches extending his
arms fully and then pop them in there
and Paul in the backroom,
Polly goes, I gotta be honest.
I was kind of glad to see that cause when
I went and against him like the first
four or five rounds, I couldn't land shit
cause that style, like it takes forever.
Just get used to it. I didn't
know what to do. He's like,
so I just thought maybe I was having
an off day. But once I see that,
I see Floyd do this kind of
the same thing. You know?
Granted Floyd fly to different
style. I don't give a shit. Yeah,
that style is legit. It's legit. You
know? I mean that's just too big a leap.
That's all it is.
Hope for Connor to go and his first
professional fight fight arguably the
greatest fighter of all time.
It's like he's 100% in the mix now.
At d and o get 50 and now it's 100% in
the mix that he's the greatest fighter of
all time. You think about
defensively, no one's even close.
No one has been hit as little
as him and honor him. Yeah.
I used to beat everybody and obviously
fought Conor different way than he fired
everybody else.
That's a fact.
But he'd kind of hit it more than any
fighter that every huge Kudos to Conor and
Floyd,
but especially Connor.
When's the last time you saw an
exciting Floyd Mayweather fight?
True Condo went at him. Yeah. That's when
we kind of acid the fight. I made them,
I turned them into a Mexican. Oh, that's
hilarious. Do you say that like, yeah,
he didn't know that.
No condom. I miss a lot
of,
Connor brought the fight out of them for
the first time since I don't know who
you can say, well, let's finish
was Victor Ortiz? That was shit.
That was kind of a cheap shot.
You didn't really didn't bring it to him,
but just daughter brought it out of him
and this was legit. It was cool, man.
And when I watched it the second time,
knowing the result,
then you really appreciate what Floyd's
doing because although Connor did catch
him,
he definitely caught him with a heart
upper cut in the first round that's shut.
Yeah. That was interesting
because that was like, oh shit.
Like you got to realize mind your p's and
q's. This guy's legit. But Conor never,
even though he clipped him with that shot,
it never really heard them
except the one shot to the body.
Which I was surprised.
I got to be honest in my prediction.
I thought Connor was gonna do well
like you did in the first rounds.
I called that.
I thought he was gonna run four to five
rounds and then I thought he would want,
I thought maybe that Upper
Cup would wobble them and
that would be enough to win
Connor kind of the
spectacle but just it Kinda,
you know Floyd's Chin and you know just
the boxing power's a little different
man. It definitely is different. And I
don't think Conor is loading up either.
You know,
I don't think Conor is a really like
digging in on these shots cause I think he
was probably concerned
about his endurance.
You've got to realize also this
fight was relatively short notice.
So short notice that I had already booked
the DC Improv in advance and it was
sold out by the time they
announced the fight. Correct.
So are not the DCM Prov that
the Warner theater in DC.
So if you think about that,
that's fucking months in advance.
Three months they did this
fight was announced three
months ago. That's nothing.
That's nothing for this man.
Not to do have a fight.
Most of the time a fight like this
is six, seven months out. Oh my God.
They'd be more, when did they announce
Canelo triple down a long time in a while.
I think between the time they announced
it and then when the fight starts,
I got to feel like it's five months
at least. At least. Which is norm,
I would assume. But, but at
least they, but they also,
boxing was smart because they set it up.
Right. So the at Canelo is a Chavez Jr.
That was a joke,
but that was literally just a setup to
get him to trip to triple g and they both
knew it. So you're looking at basically
a year in the making and before that,
what two years in the making.
And here's more importantly during
that entire time they're both box.
Connor's not,
I mean he's not really sure if he's
going to actually have this boxing match
with Floyd Mayweather it.
Right.
So he knocks out Eddie Alvarez
and then somehow or another,
the rumblings get started. But that's
just not enough time. Well, did you,
did you hear lunch to prepare for Floyd?
I agree. Especially in that arena.
The best of all time in that
different arena. Floyd goes, listen,
I tried making this fight before this and
the, you'll turned it down and he goes,
I will see what happens. And then he
goes, then I came back and was like, Yo,
this how much money we could make. He
goes, and then they were like, all right,
let's do it. He goes, but I tried
making this fight a while ago.
But even before this, yeah,
I remember the discussions,
but to be the be that close, like
when they actually announced it. Okay,
this is actually happening. Crazy.
It's crazy to have it so quickly.
Especially this man to have a fight. Yeah,
it's nuts. So if something like that,
if you gave Connor like six months,
maybe he could get in better
shape where he could survive.
He's always going to fit.
He's,
he's never going to be
against a guy like Mayweather.
It was so efficient and
his movement is so crisp.
And this is how I was describing
it to a friend of mine. I was like,
does your friend have all boxing or
martial arts background any fast?
He was trying to figure out like why he
would get so tired. Gotcha. And I said,
I go, okay, when you tie
your shoe, you tie your shoe.
You don't even think about it.
He just called right now.
But if you have to think
about tying your shoes,
it takes more energy so you don't want it.
And you have to think.
And then you've got your
tents. I go Floyd's just tying
the shoes. He's reacting.
Yeah. He's just so, he's so good.
He's been doing it so long that he's
just got it ingrained in his movements.
Connor has to think way
more than Floyd does.
And Floyd is constantly pressuring them.
So cars backing up all the time,
which wears you out. And also
the, the volume of punches.
He set a really high pace.
He thought,
I think he thought he was gonna be able
to stop them. Well, maybe a little more.
Stop him from coming forward. He
wasn't prepared when, you know,
when Floyd put his head in his chest and
did work the raft and allow him to get
his rest in the clench. But
listen, at the end of the day,
I'm all about the glitch in the Matrix,
man. I think Connor's is a glitch.
It was so much fun that even
pulled this off. It's awesome.
He didn't dishonor the sport. I thought
he did really well. Um, the only,
I told colonics and I'm proud of you,
man. What he did. We win or lose.
This is not, his belief in himself is
incredible, but even that is not enough.
If you find a better boxer
and your body gets tired.
So that's what we saw in that fight
in the beginning of the fight.
If he could have maintained
somehow or another,
if he was in good enough shape that he
could maintain the pace that he had.
He had in the first three rounds
for the entire 12 you had a fight.
It's a well a way different fight
because he's dangerous. He's quick,
he's moving away.
He has a huge endurance problem.
And this is like something
that comes back to for boxing.
Obviously you don't think he has
insurance prime in UFC as well. He May.
Cause if you look at his
[inaudible] Nate Diaz fight the,
I went five rounds the first fine.
Yeah. But if you look at his attributes,
that same durance is, you
know, and everyone knows
I'm a counter, a Dick Rider.
But if you go on,
you know his strengths I,
I'd say it's at the bottom as far as
his strengths. I agree it's not bad.
Where it's like, you know, it's
not good. It's not good. Look,
here's the best endurance in the sport.
Mighty mouse for sure. He doesn't count.
He's out. True. You're 125 pounds.
You're out. Cain Velasquez counts.
Cain Velasquez did count cats at the,
at the height of his career. You know,
who else has phenomenal cardio and Neil
Magni, no magnet. You don't mind me?
The Gazelle has some
phenomenal, phenomenal cardio,
uh, amazing pace. Sodas. A,
you look at guys, you know Jon Jones
has gift card. Very good cardio. Yeah.
Might be BPO. We'll figure it out. I
was on and we need to talk about that.
You can't trust anything.
I'll just pointing. Was that
how disappointed he was?
That broke my heart. John Jones.
Dude, you broke my heart, dude. Jamie.
Jamie sent it to me. I was at a
universal, my wife and my kids,
I had no doubt was texting you because
what was I doing? Uh, I forget.
Oh,
I
think, oh, I was working in for showtime
and I have my phone and then I, I look at,
I have 70 miss tax and 23 minutes called
like, what the fuck happened? I'm like,
someone died who died? And I look,
it's like John Jones, like, ah.
So when as well with the hi Jamie sent
to me. I thought it was a show. Me Too.
I thought the people were messing with
me. I looked at my phone, I was like,
this is, and then you sent to me that
you're the first one it takes. I'm like,
is this real? You went, yes. Well Ron, my
heart, John Snow. Once you start talking,
once he started talking back and forth
with the golden snitch that go on Snitch,
there's zero jokes there.
And listen,
when the golden snitch
comes out with something,
they've brand that pisser through
a ton of test. It's not like,
it's not fake news. His was
plastered shit. Apparently a court,
well, hold on. I can't, I don't think
I can say this because I had an expert.
I talked with an expert about this drug
and he fucking dropped some knowledge on,
okay, this is what I've
heard. This may not,
may or may not be true because this is
the reason why I don't tell you to say
this cause I'm, I'm
not, I'm not 100% aware.
Maybe we can find some
information online available.
What I had heard is that this
drug is not detectable in blood.
That it's a drug that's detectable in
urine and they have to in a new test,
right? The test, they said a new test.
What from what I heard too is the
Usada is they have a new test,
obviously the only announcing,
hey we're doing this now.
Everyone welcome to the party.
And this drug was also, it's,
it's very common around power lifters
cause you can use in competition and by
the time you get tested after
it has, uh, hours, a half life.
So the shelf life is super short but you
take it and makes you super aggro and
strong. So it they, and they go,
it's so hard to obtain legally.
Most everyone gets a black market.
And when you get a black market,
you don't know where it's coming from.
And a lot of time,
and this happens with a lot of
power lifters in their athletes,
when they test hot for this,
it's because they got a bad batch
or something else mixed into it. Oh,
this is gone from my super
knowledgeable dude who knows about it.
It makes you angry or Oha confident.
Passive.
And it goes in it. It lasts maybe
an hour, maybe two hours Max.
And that's how your
system, he goes, he goes,
so that makes sense by someone would fail
directly after cause it no, no, no, no,
no, no. He, he failed after the
weigh in. That's when he failed.
This is after the weigh in? I don't
think so. Yeah. He sure. Yeah. Yeah.
We'll either way. Yeah. Well
maybe it's like lingering.
Well that's what he's saying. What
he's saying. He's saying, well,
but also I heard that they would use
the new test to maybe someone gave him a
tainted sandwich. Maybe some tainted Dick
Pills. Either way. He broke my heart.
I'm off. I'm off the train. I'm off
the God damn train and I'm sick of the,
we have no idea what happened. It was just
Dick Pills. I'm like, I'm out. I'm out.
How dare you? Well, is he offering up any
possible scenario for what happened? No.
He tweeted out like, this is when I find
out who my real friends are. Hashtag boy
fuck that noise.
That sounds like you're feeling sorry.
She's just ain't helping
you out of this one.
So much to be grateful for the UFC
money, but yeah, that's good. Um, yeah,
he's got a nice family. It's true.
Good friends. Hopefully whatever.
Whatever the fuck is happening. But here's
the thing, man. They have a second fire.
Joe,
listen to it multiple times as much Sada
since the golden snitch has been around
and he's a motherfucker. I liked the guy.
But if you're a fighter, motherfucker,
well, hey, he's doing exactly what
he supposed to do. Kind of doing,
staring with sport baseball first.
Now you're hitting all the fighters are
ruining it because they know what the
fucking parameters. I agree.
I agree. I don't look,
look, here's the thing about this fight.
Do you think Dana's ever like God,
what kind of testing was done for this
Floyd? Maybe with Conor McGregor fight
those new lights. What did he at Brody?
I like where you're doing the place, man.
You know what man? I like the curtains
right when I pulled the new studio,
I'm gonna do the curtain.
Yeah, you should man. Uh, yeah,
but Novitsky is a guy that you
don't want on your bad side. Oh No.
But do you ever think days like Damn Bro,
relax me.
But Jesus,
they knew what they were getting into
and you know what they just decided,
this is only one way
to clean up the sport.
Bring in the guy who was the very best
to catching people for doing drugs. Bam,
Bam, Bam. Did they do, and
here's the thing, Jon Jones,
since you sought us, come in,
he's failed three out of four tests.
The only one he did a full on
was a copper OSP. Coke is coke,
coke is coke. Coke once.
Oh, so that's fine.
Oh,
coke,
you a few lines and just fucking
Vandelay Silva pride style. Just,
um, how can we can't drink like
a giant monster energy drink.
That's one of the sponsors APP cause
it's not coke because it's like Goddamn
turn can, have you ever done coke?
No. Haven't have you now? No.
It's one of the few I know,
but I didn't do heroin but one
when I did get my knee operated on,
they had me on a drip on a,
I guess it was morphine,
morphine and I get to hit the
button every time you launch this.
And I would just, Bram was
firing her name. You I celebrate.
I guess they let you fire it into
a point where you can't die. Oh,
that's can't imagine you'd be able to
keep hitting that button and then dodge
that? No, they can't.
I remember, I wonder,
I wonder like what the limit is and how
many times. It depends who you are, right?
Because you probably have a high pain
tolerance for with your background,
but also I was bored.
So if I'm bored and you would give this
me this button and let's get [inaudible]
watching some terrible local television
show, the teaching channel. Oh,
I'm sure. We'll see. It's
super addicted. I'm sure. Yeah.
Someone gave me a bunch of
uh, these, these gummies,
these weed gummies and I can't rest it
and I'm always thinking about something.
So I took the weed gummy and Mars
attack was on, that shit was happening.
I've seen it so many times. It's, I feel
like it's always on late at night for me.
It's like my go to,
it's a great movie.
It is like a truly great movie,
right?
And it's so like silly,
like everything all done and
the cast is just phenomenal.
They want to Redo that.
I feel like,
didn't Jack Jack Nicholson played
two different people in that movie.
He played like the high roller, like
Vegas Guide and else played the president.
Yes. Jim Brown's in that
movie. That's right.
Jim Brown's fucking everybody up plays
like a fucking alien up character.
Look at,
Tell Your Dad Jack Nicholson is the high
roller and then Martin Short's in it to
go get the fucking picture
of his body in Jesus Christ.
Look how cool the alien looks.
Thank God. They were awesome man.
Look at his clothes.
That was when the alien was the girl.
Remember he thought he's going to hit,
she was all hot. Yeah. And that was peers,
peers. Bronson was in it. Yes.
He was in it too. Am I crazy?
Ad and then remember his him and uh,
what's her name?
Whatever from sex and the city.
I remember her and him get their heads get
switched on to dots, right? Yes. Right.
They cut their heads off and put them on
dogs. What a fucking great movie. Oh Gee.
We were at Jack Black.
He had the military and he just runs
out and gets murked right away from the
family on TV. He's all,
fuck it. I'm going in.
Rushes in. There was so fun. See
if you could pull up just a video.
We could see them moving around.
I feel it. Especially for a 1996.
This was some Avatar Shit.
All my God.
Yeah, man. I did a, uh,
a movie or why was it that I did,
I did something with, one of the Gat
was Christina Applegate and that to, oh,
what's her name? Who was that girl? She
like it's, and that was the girl from, uh,
the big Lebowski. Tara Reid.
Wasn't that her? It's not her. Oh,
that was that. That was like the
yoga bitch who was all into it.
And remember shot releases the dose.
What's her name? Warren Beatty's wife.
Annette Bening. That's who
that is. That's that is,
that's that is here
come the power from all
good dude. Look at this. Not Be too rash.
Interested in the White House
to meet with a really broad
boom. It's an, that Benning
was with Jack Black.
Jack's a
shotgun.
Cultural misunderstanding about being
prepared for a few changes to what?
Oh,
what a great,
the marshy can teach us professor.
Quite a lot about
her.
I forgot about the giant robot.
Me To really,
grandma figures it out by music kills him.
Oh,
that's right. Spoiler alert.
The crazy ass grandma.
We all make mistakes. Mr President. I
remember they swallowed a nuclear bomb.
They like tried to Newco, man. They
landed a balloon then inhaled it.
Tim Burton, shout out to Tim. Tim
Burns a pirate. No backer. Hell yeah.
He's made some awesome movies
and they're always so weird too.
It's like what a crazy guy. He must
be. It must be up bat shit. Crazy.
That's right. He did pee
wee. Which one did he do?
The first one was the greatest
man. What time did Batman? He did.
He did the early Batman did to write it.
First of all,
he sold Michael Keaton as
Batman. Yeah, that's right.
Just about the joker movie
that they just announced.
He's not going to be in there.
Make a Martin Scorsese and Todd Phillips
or making a joke or a world stories.
That's my boy.
I thought Jared Leto.
Everybody loved him as a joke or not
going to be in this. No, but he has a d.
You're talking about two different ones,
so Jared loves doing a spin off joker too,
but this one my boy taught Feldman put
together with Todd Phillips and Martin
Scorsese, Scorsese, Saz, Jesus
Christ, speech impediment. Anyway,
the joker origin story on deck.
Todd Phillips got silver.
Martin Scorsese and it's dark.
It's like a dark joke or like how as
a kid he had like a permit smile and
everyone made fun of them and it's
like on the streets of Brooklyn,
it's like super dark, real. I can't wait.
Who's playing the joker and I
don't think they announced yet.
I'm going to make the announcement
hair. It's going to do it. Yeah. Right.
I can't wait to, I love that
stuff. A tricky role. Right?
Like Heath Ledger did it,
you know that's one of those roles were
like, Jack Nicholson did it. Ooh, cheers.
Levels killed it too.
They sit on set.
He would like send the cast like weird
shit in the mail. He went full joker.
He'd send him like dead rats in the mail.
I'm going to have to take, I'm like, Bro,
come on now.
I get the whole joke or thing that
in the mail send me like Gucci Cape.
You learn for God's sakes,
not the Goddamn snakes keeps sending.
He was in a movie that documents his
issues with a record company that Jamie,
you're always recommending. What's that
called again? If Jared veterans in it,
it's called the other day, I'll
look at Real Brooklyn. It's a,
it's something about, um, his band,
his band seconds for mark. Yeah.
They had some deal or are the record,
it's called artifact. Artifact.
That's the name of the documentary.
So he had some deal with a record company
and couldn't get out of it. And it was,
apparently they made a brutal
documentary about it and it got that,
won all these awards and on
that flight got to tell you,
I've gotta be honest with you. When I
see like awards in between those leaves,
when they write things in which we,
those leaves,
I ignore it cause it looks pretentious.
Frames.
I'll speak it.
It must be good.
Why do you have what you have to say
framed in between fern leaves is this
ancient Rome,
what the fuck are you doing?
Because this was this hieroglyphs
it doesn't work at all with me.
We're just the opposite.
It's like when I see a company that
says world's best coffee, I'm like,
I gotta try it on that.
You shouldn't.
You should start framing all your posters
that you send out for your Gig. Leaves.
Quotes about you. I'll make a quote.
You could put it in inside leaves.
I'll say he's fucking hilarious.
It's like you put it in between two least.
What am I funny as friends between two
palm leaves. Joe Says he's all right.
Get tickets here.
Why the fuck is with the palm leaves man?
Fishel stupid. Pull that back up again.
That shit looks stupid. God, I see that.
I'm like, this shit must be good. First
of all, why do they have five of them?
Get the fuck Outta here.
Kenn palm leaves cause that movies.
That's why does Jared lentils involved?
That's why no,
you get 10 palm leaves you took up on it.
Make those quotes bigger so I can
actually read in my reading glasses.
Look at much smaller. The quotes
are then the fucking, the subtitle.
It's a bunch of independent awards.
Gun independent film awards.
Audience Award Winner Doc, New York
City Festival. Official selection. Oh,
it's all bullshit.
Toronto International Film Festival.
People's Choice Award South by
southwest 24 beats per second.
Official selection. Oh, you put that,
you put that in inside of palm leaves.
That's official selection bullshit.
One one's getting shit. Melbourne,
Melbourne International Film Festival.
Official selection.
He just want to have your
shit and in palm leaves.
See that's exactly what I'm saying.
That's why they have the quote so small.
They're fucking with you shop and
he'd just eaten it up. Eat it up.
I'm going to go home and watch it.
Don't let them get you with
those goddamn leave shop.
They got me brother every time.
Every fucking time. I'm not,
I'm not impressed by leaves.
No.
How about one good quote from somebody
that I think I respect their opinion.
Legit act or like I enjoyed
this move and Martin Lawrence,
he
always taught the fucking record
business was shady. Kevin Hart.
Yeah, that'd be great. That'd
be great. Yeah. Selection.
What does that mean? You didn't win? Did
you win or did you not? When you want,
you want some cool awards and even win
that award. That's an official selection.
You get selected bitch.
That doesn't mean shit.
Can't put that inside of palm leaves.
Hugger picked a date with that girl.
Did you fuck her? No, no. She selected me
to go the selected me. There's something,
I just, it just have Brock I brought up
because I just thought there's something
interesting about Jared Leto suits.
You guys think about the SA.
He's got a pseudonym that
he'd direct Sunder Savile
new co Cubans.
Cubans I think befallen me.
I just say you see it pop up from time
to time directed it. It's his name.
Oh that's smart. Cause he doesn't
want people to think about him.
He just wants them to think about
the de moving pig an easier name.
But can we just call him bart onset?
Barneys happens.
Maybe it was on like fucking
some shit. Dude. He did a,
the MTV awards last night before. Like
he's all, he's sponsored by Gucci.
Soy is like way too much. He has Gucci
scarf. Cape the class is all this shit on.
Just because they sell it doesn't
mean you have to wear it anyways.
So they're asking,
they're asking him about his appearance
and like his performance. He's like,
trust me.
You've never seen anything like this?
I don't want to give it away and how
much Jared little fan, I was like,
this can be some shit. This motherfucker
just did the PR. You mean the Predator?
He just did the night vision
Predator thing. Look at
this. Come on with the home.
Would he do, he just did the Predator
vision. We did this in the 90s
look, that's it. That's the whole video.
He was like, it's like some Avatar Shit.
You've never seen this before.
It's kids. First of all,
you're not really obsessed with this,
like he's obsessed with himself.
So that's part of the problem.
And then second of all,
you probably know the same drugs he's on,
but if you work go full screen with that.
I don't feel like you're
giving the full faculty.
You're talking about the Predator now.
It's a little bit more than that.
It's kind of freaking out. Well,
that's kind of detailed. Kind
of like it. He's got a hat on.
You can see it through the hat.
It's not that creative though.
I feel like interesting that you
say this and he's a creative dude.
Maybe it's good.
Maybe if you're high on ecstasy,
this would be the best video
ever. Yeah, he might be right.
I don't know how much that
has to play into it too. Are
they good band? Yes. He's,
he's phenomenal. I've never literally
never heard their music. I like the,
you would know
they've been around since the late nine.
That boy can kind got a lot of kids behind
them. Well else people dancing on son.
I like the answers dude house.
If everywhere you went you had dancers
be kind of cool is bear.
You don't think that looks good now?
The hair has been due to,
how bout,
how bout this Joe Mtd fucked
up so bad and I love him too.
How would they fucked up? How about
cause Jared Leto toward, with Chester,
the guy commit suicide for Lincoln Park
and with the guy from uh, Soundgarden.
Who else commits suicide? He's
known him. Two of his best friends.
So they have him do an open
monologue for him, right? Yeah.
Like just tell him like how great they
were and he goes, all right. Uh, let's,
let's cut to the last time.
Chester performed on stage here and
they're like on top of Hollywood and he's
singing and MTV cuts the new Mintos.
Gav,
you had your meant fresh
breath today and they cut.
They just cut it off and they come back
like let's, hey, it's Nikki Minaj his ass.
Yeah. They like did this whole
dedication to them and then halfway,
not even halfway me. 20 seconds to
performance. Cut It to commercial. Huh?
Is Rough. Why would they do that? I
don't know. When they play the full song.
I don't know.
People are so
upset. They thought was so disrespectful.
Send an accident. I don't know.
I don't think so. I think they're just
like, oh, we gotta cut the brake kit.
That meant those commercial
man. I, you know, look,
I'm very biased about this because I
don't interrupt podcasts with commercials,
but there's a big difference between like
watching shit on Netflix and watching
shit on regular TV or watching shit on
HBO and watching Shit on regular TV.
I don't watch commercials. The you get
brought out of the of the, like the,
the whole hypnotic
effect of seeing a show.
The breaks your focus a hundred percent
if game of Thrones at commercial,
there's sometimes the game
of Thrones I don't breathe.
Like when that red wedding, I was
like, oh dude, just after just wait,
this is shit happens
with certain said Dragon.
Try not to get so close to anyone
because everyone dies the fuck up.
You can't get close. They got close.
I cannot get some handling Polisi man.
I'm like, Oh Shush, Shush, Shush,
shush. We can't talk. You can't talk.
I can't say any slave. She's such
a, she's the mother of all drag.
I know she's not a slighter. She
never slay the dragons. That's true.
You know what I'm saying though? Yeah. To,
yeah. There's like interruptions in the,
in the, in the game of Thrones. It's like
I'm in the zone, man. I'm in the zone.
I tried to watch him walking dead once on
regular TV in real time and I was like,
I can't even do this.
I just flipped through all the chat.
As soon as commercial I flipped through,
I just record them so I
can fast forward through.
I don't get how they make
money off these ads anymore.
Well that's what my point is that this
is a very ineffective way to promote
things and I think it would
probably be a more effective way,
like think of all the ads they have
in a show, right? If all these shows,
wouldn't it be like me?
Way more effective if they had one
very good or two very good ads at the
beginning of the show and they say like
game of Thrones is brought to you by
boom, they do it. If you've
got to do that. I agree.
Having in the beginning and know that
this show sponsored this entire episode so
that the episode doesn't have to have,
that's just like they do that
business greedy. They do it, but yeah,
they want to do those 32nd spots to
get all that money for the network.
But the thing is like those breaks,
they ruined the art so they
make the creation worse,
so it makes it less valuable.
It makes it less valuable to sell ads on.
And also no one's watching them.
They know it's not going.
You're going to get a fraction of the
people watching them and a lot of people
are going to be upset by them.
I agree. And it does. It does.
They just don't work that
the advertisement agency,
you know that come around off,
see podcasts and cause if someone's going
to listen to your show for three hours
a day, you know, it's
just a different dynamic.
But you're also not up there
reading, you know, whatever.
Sponsor me on these we
have coming to me undies.
You're reading in the middle of like,
if you're like, hold on Britain,
let me do this real quick.
A lot of people do do that.
I just don't think it's the
right way to do it anymore.
I just think the only reason why we're
doing it that way is because everybody
always did it that way before.
That's how you saw it on television.
That's how you heard it on the radio.
They always interrupted for these ads.
I don't think that's the
most effective way to do ads.
I just think that we got used to doing
it that I think it upsets people.
Definitely does. I think it turns
people off where they're like,
fuck that product. You know
when people used to say, well,
what if someone has to
get up to take a leak?
Well do you don't have to do that anymore?
You can pause things now.
You can watch HBO on pause it.
I mean we have different control over
media now and ultimately we're going to
get to a point where you can watch
things almost everything's going to be on
demand the way Netflix does it.
That's the future. It's the future.
Imagine what donut comedy central
special and there's commercials to your
special.
That's where mine was my last special.
I had a break it up and they edited it
for commercials and I even like recorded
it for commercials. Like I knew
that it was going to be 44 minutes.
I had to do it during this constraint
and these were when we're going to drop
things and so it had to
make sense when you shut,
shut it off and then went to commercial.
It's very complicated to edit that way.
It's tough enough as it is. Yeah. And it
does, it's not good to watch it that way.
It's just not me.
It's better than not watching it at all.
But the best way to watch
something is all the way through.
But here's the question is say if
you're a company, right? Like, uh,
outside of podcasts, which are pretty
easy, just do the ads in the beginning.
How do you, how do you sell things
now? Like say if you're, you know,
pick a product. If you're mentos
Mentos to fucking night, I, uh,
I,
uh,
sponsor that show and I pay enough where
they don't need the other ad revenue
and I get at the beginning and the end.
But is it worth it for them?
Because that's a tangible
amount of money, right? If,
if you're going to have one
sponsor for the entire show,
think of how many sponsors the video
music awards must have. Like, yeah,
it doesn't,
how many of them don't do this?
Performance is brought to you by Pepsi.
And then they hit it, you know, which is,
which is almost better than doing
a full Pepsi commercial gas.
I don't know. Still don't
want to hear it. Like what?
How do you advertise something
without interrupting?
Something else has got to be a
way because it seems so sneaky,
but they've always done it this way.
You're watching something.
You don't want to hear the ad. You've
got to sit through the ad. All right.
All right. All right. Get back to what
I like and then you get back to it,
but I wonder if there,
they must be seeing a return because
otherwise they'd stop. Right.
Obviously I bet it's down,
but the advertising agency so big then
she's so big because who really watches
things live now besides sports,
like game of Thrones. I mean,
I'm in season four for God's sakes.
Came out years ago.
There's other shows like my other
shows, hard knocks HBO, no commercials.
I've just, I've, and if there's
commercials, I literally just,
I won't even see one who's really
sitting there when it's live.
I watch commercials on Hbo
for upcoming programs though.
Those aren't really commercials.
They're not selling you a product.
They're showing you other cool shit there.
Developer previews at the movie. Yeah,
I take that and here's some cool
shit you might want to watch.
You're not selling you anything.
Exactly. But even at AMC when they,
those delicious ice cold sodas
pop out, I'm like, you know what?
I might have to have one. Yeah,
but that's before the movies.
He price back that and they also have
that after they showed you a bunch of
really cool shit with the preview.
You've already got my approval or any
friends or if you get their real real
early, it's a slideshow.
All those are fucking
a loser. When are you going to start
showing me some things that lights are on?
Bright white screen and then it's
just like ag. Yeah, that's right.
It's like a local Italian restaurant.
Oh,
with the best bread in the
fucking things in between.
We'll call leaves or their awards
are in between leaves. Yeah.
It's just you and your buddy. Yeah. I
feel like it makes you feel like a loser.
Like, oh my God, we're
idiots right here so early.
You know there's a lot of these movie
theaters that are taken off that are in
places where you get assigned seating
and they sell booze and they bring real
food. That's what I do. There's a lot of
those now man. This ton of different ones.
Yeah, I pick you go there. It's
so nice. My so many of them now.
You don't have to like, it's good
food too. Like really good. Yeah.
Some dude was eating a
steak next me and shit.
Does that synopsis here we go to that one.
No arc lights good too.
There's some really good ones.
Well they figured it out man.
It's like the same thing that
airports have figured out. Hey,
we don't have to have only shitty food.
How about you have a nice
little restaurant right
here in the airport and they
started doing that with like Wolfgang
puck's at lax and then they have lemonade
salary. There's a lot of good stuff
at the airport now. Good coffee.
You can get real food.
San Francisco has like
straight up five course meals.
Real food. Dia has a chop
house. Steak House. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. New York has a JFK, JFK,
some serious restaurants. Jason
Kilar, Italian food. Really killer.
Like really good. Some serious
shit. Yeah, there's everywhere.
Has figured that now. They're
like, look, we, you're,
you've got people coming in and out.
A lot of these people are business people.
Like people have money. Yeah. They
don't want to just eat McDonald's.
Even the plain foods getting better too.
They have an Asta Rhea and lax.
Now I know like a fame,
like a fancy schmancy little place.
We it with a tasting menu. I love
that shit. I'm getting hungry.
Let me tell you know, he's still sticking
to the Kito Diet. Uh, I went pescatarian.
Oh,
how dare you now just to mix it up.
How did keep forever and I'd go back to
it. I'm, I'm asking the 10 only fissured,
eat scallops and muscles to scalp
and muscles. I'm him lobster.
My huge lobster fan.
How dare I made some lobster.
Grilled it up real proper.
Like grilled it up.
Why don't you just throw it in the dirt
and let it get heated up with a son?
Grilled. Blockbuster. You don't? What
do you like? Your labs are boiled.
Boiled like a man. No, that's the JV.
See Grill, that thing.
I don't kill anything.
I just buy it from the
store tales. Fucking, Oh,
you're grilling blabbing for God's sakes.
Don't lobster tails.
Jesus Christ. What do you do? What
the hell? Fuck. And I'm alive.
Oh, fuck up. You get them live
from two. It's 2017 fucking.
What are you talking about?
Grocery stores have tanks.
You'd go to a grocery store.
Jamie,
what's the last time you saw
God damn lobster tank. They do.
You go to Ralph's or some shit and
maybe that the inhumane tank [inaudible]
to get out. Do they have it?
A lot of places? Yes. Listen,
I've seen that since I was a kid.
Have when a Gelson's right up the
street from here. You go there.
Does a tank of water scoop
up a fucking laugh, sir.
Until you give me that one right there.
It's about two pounds, sir. Okay,
we'll take that one. Oh, that's
a good one. Am I batshit crazy?
I haven't seen that in four. And you only
go to whole foods. That's why I'm fancy.
You don't fuck around your Amazon bought
whole foods here about that ratio,
change slashing prices and their stock.
As soon as they bought it went boom, boom,
boom, boom. They paid whatever,
12 billion. Here's what I
put up. 22 billion of that.
You want to make some money? Yeah, sure.
Get rid of this fucking people in the
parking lot that harass you when you're
walking out with a car,
you got ice cream.
It's 150 degrees outside and they're like,
can I have two minutes for gay rights
finger in front of your face? Like,
Hey, I hope man, I vote for gay rights.
You can't just get me your ambushing me
when I'm coming out with my fucking cold
food. This guy did that to me.
He stuck his finger in my face.
They said Gleason's again,
g Gelson's Gleason's is a gym
and that's right at Gelson's.
They did that shit again.
Yeah, no fuck that place.
He happened to me once where the guy said,
can I have two minutes for gay
rights or one minute if go down.
That only happened to me once, but I've
been stopped for a bunch of other things,
a bunch of other things. Sometimes
they have a whole fucking table set up.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Third
Street or Abbot Kinney.
There's table set for Syrian
children, blacks, Asians.
Here's the problem with those things.
I don't have the time to research where,
where this money's going. I don't
trust people that's about for showing.
Give the kid money for sure.
There was some girl look real
aggressive way back in the day.
It's like more than 10 years ago at the
airports and black chick with a bucket
and open bucket and she had some binder
with a bunch of photos in it and stuff
and she was saying, you know,
we're collecting money for this.
That sounds legit and quiet.
And she goes,
and she was like real aggressive
about it. I go, yeah, I go, you,
you have a binder and you have a bucket
that you want me to put money in.
And she was like, well fuck you then. And
I was like, fuck me that. Oh, okay. I go,
that makes a lot of sense. You're super
charitable. That's what you're all done.
I go, you're stealing people's money
with some stupid scam. Like give a,
you have a bunch of photos
of like downtrodden people
that's in some sort of a
binder that's buying plastic and you can
close this binder and you tuck it cause
you're going to get busted and you get
this weird bucket that's wide open.
You could scoop anything out of it.
And then I asked you about it.
You say fuck you. Was there
any money in there? Oh yeah,
there's like a couple bucks
in there already. You know,
it was one of those weird things.
It's like who's to stop you from taking
out my rust that like, I was off of, uh,
the 90 the other day and I came to
stop and I saw this huge banner said,
help us pay for our father's funeral. It
was like four black guys. And I'm like,
God, I came a game, we'll 10 spot,
not a 20 minutes. I get crazy.
But the problem is you don't know if it
really is it mean if this girl really
was trying to raise money for a
charitable cause, it's really good.
She didn't represent it very well.
Could. She just seemed like a scammer.
Like I got out. I was like, look at
that binder. It's just some pictures.
They're folded up in a binder
and some printed piece of paper.
There's just too much stuff going
around. Yeah, yeah. Bad stuff.
The bucket and an open top.
But can you just reach in that bucket?
You could drop things in them.
Like where's the accountability there?
How do I show girl?
But that's a good scam.
Like if you're a person
that wants to scam people,
that's like a great scan is a
smart move because the car, oh,
you're gonna make money, dude. If you
go to Vegas or a not Vegas, Lex rather,
and you're walking like down that where
people are arriving, first of all,
they just want you to get the fuck away.
They'll throw $5 in there,
maybe 110 maybe one at a time. They'll
give you money. Why not attend?
Gives you money, you'd think seen hundreds
of people and the people are gone.
They not.
It's not like you're doing this in a
restaurant where they can see you do it to
one purchase coming. Yeah.
Everybody's constantly filtering out.
I think security is going
to let you do that. Well,
I think that's why she had the binder
and that's why I like the whole bucket
thing was very bizarre. It was a while
ago, so yeah, long time ago. Security.
You might move along later. Yeah,
this is more than 10 years ago,
but I'll never forget like how aggressive
she got with me to the point where my
adrenaline fired up when I was like,
Whoa, this girl might like swinging at me.
That's why he still at worst. Yeah. She
was like, she when she said, fuck you,
she was like in my face.
You can tell like he was enough to know
that she is definitely a hit people
before and she's not
playing. It was, it was a,
it was just a person that was a little,
just a little too aggressive little
teenage kid saw. I'm like, Whoa,
am I going to get in a fight here?
You get to that,
that feeling like am I have to get in
a five minute check? Airports, nerves.
Dude, I, when I was in the
back after the fight, right.
So again, I'm with heard about
this. Yeah. Tell him about this.
Can I just clear it up now? So many
people wouldn't blow me up. So again,
I'm with judge Crawford, Amir Khan, Berto,
and I'm in the back and they're saying how
good Connor did. I'm like, yeah, great.
You know, I thought it was going to be
even better, you know, I'm surprised.
You know he did well and showtime one,
we go do this, a post fight show thing.
So I'm going and I see Nate
Diaz and he's by himself.
Like no one's really buying and he's by
himself and he's on his phone and I see
him and I think, Oh, same
fraternity, UFC guys.
There's no UFC representatives
there. Really? There's like Dane.
I didn't see him at the fight. I just
figured, hey, we're brothers. Yeah,
what's up man? But I was going
towards him because he looked busy.
I was going to go towards him and
whether he wanted my help or not,
I figured I know a few things
about marketing. The next
fight for him is Connor.
I'm assuming he's there to sell that
fight. That should be the next fight.
Controversy. Uh, Nate Diaz three
the trilogy, that's the fight.
So I was gonna go to him because I saw
some interviews where it's kinda hating
on Connor and I would have
spun it the other way.
He should have celebrated Connor and what
he did winning rounds against the best
of all time and saying, look, I,
I'd beat him up worse than Floyd.
Now we're gonna do this trilogy. I'm
going to end them faster than Floyd did.
Like, that should be the cell. I was
going to talk to him this. So I see him,
I'll call him my, I'm like,
oh. And they're like, come
on Brennan. We gotta go.
I'm like, let me just say what's
up to this guy and my go Nate brow.
How about that fight man, your next
biggest fight in UFC history, brother.
And he starts laughing.
He's like, Oh hell no.
How fucking stupid do you look now?
And I'm like,
I'm my calf ground like Wyatt,
he's a cal stupid.
Do you look talk in all this shit? I'm
like, Whoa, what are you doing right now?
What the hell are you doing right now?
And he keeps talking and there you
go Nate. He doesn't like that stupid.
He one rounds against
the best box of all time.
And the Nate's like he didn't win
rounds. He gave him one round. I'm like,
all right man, either way. So he gave
him, he one rounds though. What are you,
what are you doing?
And he just keeps talking shit.
And he starts like talking
about my career and I'm like,
what is going on right now? I go,
Nate, who's mad at you? I went, Neat.
I have no issues with you.
You're pointing your gun at the wrong guy.
What are you doing right now? You should
be selling this fight against Conor,
not me. I'm not the guy. I said,
I'm in skinny jeans and Gucci boots for
God's sake. What are you doing right now?
You know what I'm saying? Right. And
then like showtime was like, come on,
let's go boys. I'm like,
Jesus Christ man, keep gone.
I was just embarrassed by the
situation because he kept talking.
He kept doing this and I, this is
what, this is the part I left out.
This is what triggered him.
He was talking,
I literally couldn't hear
cause people were like,
chocolates go cause they didn't want to,
you know, a fight. So I shop, let's go.
And I, he keeps talking and
I'm like, Nate, use your words.
I can't understand a word you're saying.
Use your words.
Oh and he probably has it
lists or whatever and they'll
probably set them off.
But I have, I have no issues with
Nathan. So that's when it got ugly. Yeah.
Then he kept talking shit and I was like,
what are you going to do?
What are we doing here? And
he kept doing this. I'm like,
well what the fuck is happening?
I was so embarrassed because the show time
guys like, oh my God, who is that guy?
I'm like that. That's the guy
who's supposed to fight Conor next.
They've fought before and like, why
does he want, what was wrong with him?
What's wrong with him? I'm
like, it's just, I was so
embarrassed man. I'm like, oh,
now I have no issues with them. Do
you think the car wants I fight? I do.
You think that's a good money fight? I
do. I think it's the only fight. I think,
you know, I think it's the,
the true winner cause at those,
those fights at 70 or toss
up one and one is whatever.
Neither one should be fine at 70 at 55 of
trilogy fight makes sense for the belt.
It'd be the biggest paper you of all time.
I think it's the only five
that makes sense. You can't do,
could be Tony and Kevin Lee.
They're just not big enough stars to get
contracts because it could be as it may
the way. True. And he's, he's not
ready to fight. He's just, you know,
he's never done that. So how can
you sell? Could be right now,
like so let's say just in a perfect world
you want to do could be versus Connor
and you go on this world tour trying
to build Khabib up. You've got to rush.
You go over. Connor wants to
fight him in Russia. Crazy.
How do we know he's going to
make weight and doesn't pull out?
So it's out of the equation right now. He
needs to come back, fight someone else.
So to me, be easy to get his body
sorted out and he's a finger assumption.
Rockhold was saying that his liver
shut down and I read in an interview,
apologize. I didn't hear him
say or read in an interview.
He said that his liver shutdown,
uh,
when he was cutting weight
for the Michael Johnson fight.
And then the next fight after that,
he didn't make weight.
His body shut down for the Ferguson
fight and they cancel the fight.
I'll tell you what though,
I might to be flying in the conversation
for me and went till he gets his shit
together. I'm not even entertaining the
idea of him fighting and it looks thick.
I like Kevin League. He's bad
motherfucker package. He's a bad author.
But the thing is, he speaks well. He
looks the part talks a lot of shit,
but he's great. He dresses well. He has
all the makings of your next superstar.
Yeah. And he realizes now,
especially in the Conor Mcgregor era,
you've got to talk a lot of
shit. Yeah. Floyd set of paths.
Like you just can't win fights.
You've got to sell yourself. Listen,
Kevin Lee is only, I think
25. He's young. 25 or 24.
Yeah, find out he's 24, 25. Um,
super young right now.
Remember how brash Connor was
when he first got to the UFC?
Very similar. He's like 26, I believe.
Okay. So He's 24. September 4th.
He's almost 25.
He'll be 25 in a couple of days.
He's super talented.
Looks better every time you see him.
So he's essentially like somewhere
around Conner's age. When Connor,
he's like a year younger than
of first burst on the scene.
And Connor was nobody back then.
Nobody knew who he was. We'd do.
I had seen him on the Internet,
uh,
and from fights in England and
I knew it was really talented.
I actually went back and forth with
them. What's between us, you have to say.
So there's a few people
who knew about him,
but it was nothing like what
you see now. Nothing. Right?
Kevin Lee down the road is at 155
pounder who talks a lot of shit.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Straight. He looks great.
Speaks well, built like a brick.
Shithouse speaks well speaks well. African
American dress as well. Check, check,
check, check, check. All the boxes
checked and he can fucking fight.
So what's the biggest thing that fight
with Conor McGregor down the road? Ooh,
you're gonna need, you need more time
by here. You right down the road.
This is my thing for Connor like,
but he could do it. He go 100%.
I'll tell him to me. Kevin leads your next
big thing. However, Tevin leavers, uh,
Tony Ferguson's a Taj site,
so god good.
Oh great fight until he was another one.
Tony Ferguson down the road.
20 Ferguson can talk some shit
to Tony Ferguson is very smooth.
Tony Ferguson is very confident
and she also a Weirdo.
He's wearing his that weird vibe. You get
that weird vibe is so intense but like,
yeah, I was like no classes,
wing Chung and shit.
He does all these weird moves where he's
like get flowing on the ground rolling
around.
He does a lot of weird shit but
his endurance is off the charts.
He cuts a shit load of weight and does
it like a professional again to set can
capitalize on that and he wins by
knockout. He also Wednesday side mission,
very get the guys. He's beat two tough
death for Kevin. It's a very tough test.
Both have very good to me as far as
like potential like superstardom.
Those are the guys. Kevin Lee is that,
that's the guy right now I think. Yeah,
maybe. But if Tony Ferguson
becomes the interim champion,
it starts talking all kinds of crazy shit.
His
star will rise, man, don't get me wrong.
Does it demonstrate in rising and then
be coming like a straight up superstar
like a transcendent like Conor McGregor.
Ronda Rousey's like there's a certain,
there's a certain thing Canelo because
he's not really charismatic and he only
speaks Spanish. So with the
Mexicans it collects just Mexicans.
He twice and also like a trip,
Mexico has sort of a built in boxing
base through the king of boxing.
You're in, you're Mexican,
you're already basically, here
you go, you're selling. No,
you're good. Barely. Barely talks.
He's not, he's not entertaining at all.
The entertaining fighter
maybe or Mexicans. He's all
right. Fuck you saying no,
he's from the same hometown
is my girl. She's like, no,
he's not to interview them.
It's whatever. But Gunner Gennady
Golovkin who's equally impressive,
if not more impressive than Canelo.
He's undefeated. He Merck's everybody,
everybody. He's a goddamn murderous
body puncher and you know,
he can sound like like 150 papers,
150 200 Max.
He doesn't have the star quality and
50,000 page views for one of the very best
boxers on the planet are,
if not the best undefeated.
How about 175,000 for Andre Ward?
Crazy. 125 for the rematch. Crazy man.
That's even crazy.
It's nuts.
I don't even think it was
170 I think we looked at it.
I think we run 60 sets a real bomb on
67 and like one 25 or split again to
become like a straight
up household superstar.
It takes more than just being this bad
ass fighter and Anja looks after that.
Everything Andre Ward is like,
he's articulate, he's admirable.
He seems like he's got a great
control of his ego. He's smart.
He's a great hitter. Comes from a rough
background. That's a great stories,
but at the same trainer
since he was 12 yeah,
he's never lost Olympic gold medalist.
I wonder why he lost,
there's something that he lost
that cove left. Yeah, right.
He loves something about him that people
just don't, I don't know what it is.
I thought he lost to Kavala fight,
but I thought it was close,
but the second fight
he fuck Koval I've up.
That's what's important because
that was a big, a big turnaround.
How about Deontay wilder?
Yeah.
He's our American born
heavyweight champion.
He had come in right now with two
pizzas and we'd be like, what's up bro?
They know what stopped him out. No one
knows who he is. Crazy. It is crazy.
And he's supposed to fight or tease. I
think that's the, the room is dangerous.
I don't like that fight for him to our
teas is a bad motherfucker. And then on,
uh, at the Joshua was supposed to
fight that a Russian fellow. Um,
and then I think the winner of
those two fight, I forget his name.
It's a tough fight for, uh,
Joshua, we should win it,
but a fricking wilder has a tough fight
on and since, yeah, it's super tough.
Fight that Ortiz's he's very good.
He's a southpaw south Paul King,
they call him King Kong. Yeah, he's a
beast and I don't like that platform,
but neither one of those,
like Joshua was a big star looks,
the part speaks well knockout artists
at that great fight with Klitschko.
So he kind of has that.
But those other guys,
there's just nothing in Joshua will be
that way. It will be giant for the UK,
especially if he defends the show
a few times. Huge giant, giant,
bigger and bigger with every fight he'll,
he's got superstar status. He's great.
He's super articulate,
very reserved
in the UFC with Jon Jones out.
He's really your only next superstar
and he's a notch down from Connor.
Like there's Connor Brock Lesnar Rhonda.
They're here. Commons even above them.
And then there's your second tissue
start and he got Jon Jones. Jon Jones,
it goes, becomes the number one
fuck up of all time for sure.
Hands down if he wasn't already.
This is the biggest one that's consistent
at beating the shit out of people,
not to gone. Very consistent
and consistent at fucking up.
Now we can only hope and pray that
somehow or another there's some mistake.
How many times are we going to go over
this? Yeah, you around saying like, dude,
you're breaking our heart man.
He's so God damn good.
You watch that fight with Daniel
Carme and you're like, Jesus Christ.
He's so good. He's so good. But do we
take the PDS and the account now? Like,
how do we know what real
John Joe are we getting?
Because the one we saw with the Osp one
and it looked like shit and then as DC
the best of all time now cause he's
beat everybody including heavyweights,
but lots of Jon Jones. But
wait, Jon Jones was taken PDDs
it's just a hot mess.
It has a hot mass.
Meanwhile owes the mayor's like fucking
bring it. Opposed Amir's market.
Those donors like fucking bring it with.
That guy's got bricks for hands too.
But let me tell you something, man.
When I shook his hand after the fight,
I was like, oh, okay. You know how
some dudes you just shake their hand.
You're like, oh I get it. He's
got giant hands, dude bricks.
They feel like bricks. I think you
do that did puts hands on people.
He fucks people up. See, I think
you do. Let's say John's out, right?
Long story for years. Suspension
out. I broke my heart. See it.
Go to Japan just to the Gills
and fuck all the whores you want.
Do whatever you want. Oh right. I'm
out. I'm over it. I'm mad at them.
So then you have [inaudible] de Mer verse
Guston to fight DC a hundred percent
it's great. Fine, right? Very
Fun. Fight. Fight Gustafson
is so veteran. He's so good.
It's guests. It's Gustafson.
Coming off of that Glover fight,
I almost want to see OSTP [inaudible]
fight more people because this to former
crazy,
he just grabbed a hold of Janie.
Malik clipped him with that
left hook inside the clench.
But that's all there is though, Jo. Like,
hey, bring it on. Bring up to a five.
Like you look at it like, oh my God,
it's the other one left dinosaurs.
Especially now that rumbles out and
rumble was a stable mate. Anyway,
the word was that he was the guy that
was farmed with brumble all the time.
Oh really? Yeah. Yeah.
And he was one of the few guys that was
willing to spar with Ramos a monster.
He's a bad motherfucker. No time. He's
got the worst nickname involved. No time,
no time. No time. No time owes to mirror
what's the best nickname of all time.
The Best Kukui is pretty God.
Damn good.
That's pretty bad ass.
That's pretty good.
What's Kevin Leaves a Detroit
superstar. Yeah. That's fucking sick.
And you're from Detroit. That's
good name. Pretty sick. Oh, what?
What was the conch shell? Crunk chank. Uh,
what's the porno star two when
he wasn't he Detroit superstar.
What's Kevin leaves and they share the
same nickname because that can't, that.
That's fucking rude. Motown
phenom. Kevin Lowe. Tom, eh?
That's fucking, oh, that's
murder's not bad. That's the
best hard to market though.
Dare. Yeah. Daren Cruickshank. Is Detroit
too bizarre to you? That's my favorite.
Kevin Lee is Motown. Phenol hotel phenom.
Sas. Right, too. That's pretty good.
That's murder of this day and age.
Harder market. Axe murders. The best.
The natural. That's pretty good, man.
The testing back then was not enough
to substantiate these claims. I agree.
I agree. That's murder. Just tough
to sell the companies these days.
The prodigies. Pretty God. Damn good.
Well, Bj was as you best. Brilliant.
Pretty God damn good.
Yeah.
The phenom when Vito was mark and people
feign up who's the best right now? Bell.
Elka. Kukui think Elle.
Kukui. Yeah, I think so.
So goddamned supernatural. Boogeyman. God,
no heavyweights really have nicknames.
Let's try to think of the heavyweights.
Not really just Cain Velasquez, Steve Bay,
but Elke, didn't he call himself?
What's that Russian name? Sexy. I'm at.
That was there it goes that that, but that
nickname, people like he didn't use it.
Koreans. Other people did. Uncle
creepy. The Mexican is pretty God. Damn.
These are old. Yeah.
Acts wearing number five.
How dare you Kimbo slice.
Get the fuck out of here.
That's his nickname. It's not like
his, the natural. What's number one?
That was the sexy, sexy,
sexy Mama. He says, I see.
That'd be sick.
Yeah.
I have a girl fights with that sexy karate
hottie is not a bad, that's not bad,
dad. There's just no, there's
nothing great stuff out
there and Cyborg is not bad,
but her husband's name is cyborg too,
so it's like
you can't double Cyborg gotta do some
Cyborg or the guy that you went with a
sideboard and Silverado brew in Brazil.
Sideboards and silvers or like Joe's and
bills here. You know what I'm saying?
There's a bunch of Cyborgs,
right? There's other cyborgs.
I'm trying to think of other ones.
There's one other guy that I
know that call themselves Cyborg.
It was a Jujitsu Guy, I think. Does
anyone ever call you Joey? Never. Nah.
Really know,
but also I'm friends with
Diaz and everybody calls him
Joey until he's been Joey,
but his name is Jose. Really? Yeah.
Joey's Diaz. His name is
Jose Diaz. Oh, well yeah,
but we've always called him Joey. Yeah,
that makes sense. Yeah. You would call,
well Jose Joe. He could.
Yeah, you can for sure,
but I think growing up everybody called
him Joe. Do you have a nickname as a kid?
No. No nickname. No, just straight up
Joe. Yeah. I never really had a nickname.
Nothing too.
When I used to play pool pool halls or
the place where everybody gets a nickname,
there's,
there's so many crazy nicknames people.
A lot of times the nickname
was like where you come from?
Like white plains Charlie or Mount
Vernon. Tommy. There was a lot of that.
My nickname was Joe,
the comedian.
Real creative guys. It's so
lame. I was Joe the comedian,
but you're the funny guy in the pool.
While they knew I was a professional
comedian that would come and play pool
those like ray the fireman?
No, no, no. I was like 20.
When I first started playing pool.
It's right after I tore my
ACL, so I think I was 23. So like,
Hey, it's Bob the ups driver. Yes.
Real original theory. The fireman,
goddammit. Yeah, white plains.
Charlie was a big one.
This is like crazy little semi homeless
guys to come and play pool all the time.
He was addicted gambler.
So many guys I realized about
gambling addicts when I played pool.
I just did not know how many of them
there were because I'd never been around
them. I'd never been see like
until I started playing pool,
I didn't go places like,
uh,
like a night club type
environment or like a,
a place where a bunch of like CD
people would hang out with, you know,
pool halls or CD,
like a lot of gambling and shit
talking and people betting on things.
I didn't grow up around that.
My high school years was all
taekwondo and then after that, yeah,
it was all martial arts camp competition
and then all of a sudden I'm around
these complete degenerates,
like I'd never been around them and I'm
23 which is good life lesson though.
It was interesting.
I was a lot,
there was a lot of people
that are addicted to drugs.
There was a lot of methadone people
that would come during the day and they
would just be like half out of it and
they would play pool and they were
terrible. No one just hustling
for their money. The White House,
when they would just play pool
with each other, they would,
but they would call him the Methadone
eons and they would come in and play pool
and you just bang balls were like, they
couldn't concentrate Baldwin for real.
They could not concentrate,
you know shit.
But it's funny because it's like what
it was like was it were like a bunch of
people that were under a spell.
It would come in,
they'd be just fine and they would
play pool, but they were dull.
They were like gray. People just pass.
They're never, there was no vibrant color.
Correct. It goes on, but
the crazy thing is though,
there was a guy who was
the best player I ever saw,
one of the best players I ever saw,
and he was a heroin addict and he
would do heroin and he would do,
he would go into the bathroom,
he would shoot up and he would come out
and he would sit down on up one of those
bar stools.
One was pool stools,
you know that kind of elevated
with a thing for your drink.
He would sit there on this like this
for a fucking half an hour and everybody
knew what was going on here, that he had
to do this. He just sit there like this,
just highest shit so fucked up.
And I never been around anybody
who was on heroin either.
I've only seen everybody intervention.
They had explained it to me.
My friend Johnny, who did a bunch of
drugs would explain to me and he's like,
just going back to do his shit. I go,
[inaudible] Shit does he do? He's going,
he's going to fucking shoot up,
couldn't go shoot up and he's going to
come out and he's going to sit down for
awhile and then you have shoots for while
I was going to play cause they've just,
that ass dude he would
get up and he had no feet.
He'd be like the guy who was playing
this Guy George, the Greek George.
Yeah George the Greek was a one of
the local big time guys and he was a a
wealthy guy. He was always
gambling. He gamble high,
you know he would say like crazy shit
like it got the height of a mustard seed.
You Cock sucker and raspy guy
always smoking cigarettes.
You could smoke cigarettes indoor back
then everybody smart tire place filled
with smoke and he was gambling against
this guy and he had like some crazy
because this guy was like literally a
world class pool player and his fucking
guy didn't miss a ball and he's like
he shoots the fucking nerves off.
He goes into that bathroom and he shoots
that shit and he shoots his fucking
nerves. Off, he comes out of your cam is
a ball. The realize man, he would just,
he was so dead behind the eyes. Like you'd
look at his eyes and they were black,
like a durables,
like a strike to short young sharks.
He was just gone to or both eyes
are black is for lack as foe. Dude.
That's what he was lying. I'm telling
you, it was the weirdest thing around him.
Like he would look right through you.
He didn't see you. He was just blinked.
Grieved on heroin. He couldn't miss.
Couldn't miss maybe want to do heroin.
He's probably dead now though. Oh,
he's dead. I know he's dead. Oh, 100%.
I ran into him at a pool tournament when
I first moved to La in 1994 and this
guy tried to get me to drive
him to Compton so he could cop.
He asked me to put him, he asked me
to put him in the pool tournament.
There's a pool tournament. Um, ad
um, uh, God dammit. What's it called?
Hard Times. Hard Times.
Bill Years in Bellflower.
It's one of the biggest pool
halls in the world. Hard Times.
It's like a world famous pool hall
and it's in Bellflower, California.
And a lot of big time gamblers and top
level players used to play there all the
time. And even came out of
there like Keith McCready.
It was like the guy from the color of
money, he was the nemesis of Tom Cruise.
Legitimately one of the best pool
players in the world at the time.
Came out of there.
So this is a huge pool hall,
like one of the biggest like pro
level pool halls in the world.
And I get there and I see this guy,
they call them buffalo bill or water dog.
Those are his two nicknames.
Squatter Doug,
depending upon which part of the
country and what time of the year.
What are dogs? Cool. So I ran into
him and a I, Mike, are you playing?
What are you doing out
here? And he was like, yeah,
I just need to get somebody to
put me in the tournament. I'll,
so I'll put you in the tournament.
Like it was like, I don't know,
20 bucks or something like that.
He didn't even have 20 bucks.
Need you to front of $20 post to get
them in a tournament or whatever.
I don't remember how much it costs.
Might've been 50 bucks, whatever it was.
I was like, I'll put you in
hit or legit chance to win.
Like he was a world class player.
He's like, okay, better got to go to,
got to go to Compton so I can cop.
And I was like, what? And he was like,
you've got to drive me to calm down.
I'm like,
I'm not driving you to Compton so you
could buy heroin because if they arrest
you, they take your car. Like if I
was here with the transaction, right.
Oh they confiscate your car.
Oh, I was like, you got to,
I had a 1994 Toyota super bitch
bitch. You crazy. Super Turbo.
The cow with a big crazy stupid
purple silver. I love the purple one.
I was wanting to space it pro. My cars
are almost all sower. I hear you. Damn,
that's sick drive. That thing that Compton
and he looked the ways we do to that,
the first nice car ever had ever,
you know, I was like uh, at the time,
probably 27 ball in for
the first time I live hell.
And I'm like what should a Postmates
that shit. I was like, I have a condo.
I rent a condo right now.
Motherfuckers not given all this up.
I was like so excited. He's all sad. Oh
yeah, super sad. Super Sad. Super is that,
and he went out there and he
lost two matches in a row,
like barely paid attention.
I put him in the tournament anyway,
asked me to put them in any way
like, but $90 drugs man without
heroin he could not play well.
He was so itchy I think. I think those
guys they'd get off of that stuff.
A cold Turkey.
Like if you have a your Jones and Ford,
will you put them in a tournament
with withdrawals? Fucked up.
I don't know if it was even withdrawals,
he'd probably gotten a lot earlier
that day. He was just Jones.
I don't think it was a full withdrawal
one cause he seemed pretty, you know,
I think when they get withdrawn, Olin
does that a word. Withdrawal. Withdrawal.
They start sweating and shit and the
shape. It's like they have the seeker,
like they have the flu. I tried going off
coffee for a day and I got withdrawals.
I get headaches. I was
like sweating, clammy skin.
I'm 100% addicted to caffeine. Me 200%
I'm not mad at it though. I love caffeine.
I like life with caffeine. I
like coffee. I like the ritual.
I get up in the morning, I drink some
coffee, I'll do a little reading.
I do a little writing
sometimes to take a giant shit.
Then I worked in standard routine.
Used to work out right away,
but I found out that it's better if
I let my brain warm up a little bit.
Just get him a little foggy. Yeah, we
got them on file. You have my coffee,
take my kid for a walk
and then I hit the gym.
Sometimes I like to look at the news too,
just to make sure the world's not fucking
falling apart before I start my day.
Yeah, I might. Yeah. It's just like to
be in the know, you know I go to Google,
I have this like Google news things set
up on my phone so I'll hit that without
looking at social media and said I
don't get looking at my own stuff.
I just go and read stuff about like
what's happened in the world. Everything.
Okay, we're going to war with
Korea. We're good Santa Right.
Like to check off your shit happening.
Some fire I need to know about to light
fire season right now buddy. Dude, it's,
it's rare. 180 degrees outside
right now. It is fucking toast.
I'm sweating in here. It's the same. I
feel bad for my car dude. It's insane.
It's so bad for my car. It's
so hot. How hot it is outside.
When I came to the door to unlock,
to get in the air conditioning from our
studio was billowing out and I could
feel it on my hand.
Why the fuck outside?
It's crazy cause it's really
the world's ending bro World.
Satan's coming Houston is,
we're living in Arizona now.
It's so fucking hot. Is this like,
is it going to keep getting worse?
Like at what point does it become
uninhabitable de la yesterday, my, uh,
like girls, dad was at the
house and he just goes, Brennan,
it's only gonna get worse. I'm like,
God, I just, the heat, just the world.
Everything. Is that true? That I disagree.
It's better than ever. I disagree.
There were like, I know things
look rough right now, but if you,
if you look for bad things,
you're going to find bad things.
Here's what I think is going to be to say,
Jamie,
whenever you see like a high temperature
like today and we don't beat the record
high, whatever that was, right?
I always think about what the fuck
was going on in 1927 when it was 172
bushes like fucking pussy
and dude's just like shit.
And more. If we get to wear three piece
suits and hats, like an ass holes,
imagine what George washing my days.
They had those fucking wigs. Oh yeah.
Powdered wigs. Yes. That
would go into the courtroom
with a powdered wig on with
no air conditioning. No AC.
That stupid wig and the full get up.
What is a powdered wig like?
What does that mean? Do they put
powder on the wig? What is a powder
powder and white? Yeah. Why did they
have powdered wigs like Google that?
That's a crazy, like a crazy tradition.
Who was, I gather. It looks tight, Bro.
It's what are you wearing bro? In
England? No. Do they wear them? They wear,
I'm super obvious where like you
can see their hair underneath.
They put a little effort. The powder made,
made, made them white or whatever color.
Okay.
In 18th century,
men's wigs were powdered to
give them their distinctive
white or off white color.
Women in the 18th century did not wear
wigs but war. How'd he say that word?
Co Fewer Co fure supplemented
by artificial hair or hair from,
oh,
they had a week after 1790 English
women seldom powdered their hair.
Why did people wear powdered wig?
Click on that mental floss. You know,
why the fuck would they do it and why
did they, what does that Peru keys,
powdered wigs called Peru keys were
all the rage. Look at that fucking wig.
They would wear the goofy, his wigs.
They would like, uh, like 1970s rockers.
How weird. Centuries powdered wigs
called Peru keys were all the rage.
The chic is that say how you
say that chick is chic, right?
Hairpiece cause I always hear chic,
I don't really read it that often.
She care piece would never
ever become popular. However,
if it hadn't been for a venereal disease,
a pair of self conscious kings
and poor hair hygiene. Wow.
The [inaudible] story begins like many
others with syphilis standard 1580,
the STD had become the worst epidemic
to strike Europe since the black death.
Oh my God.
These people were all fucking each other
to death according to William. William,
how do you say that name? Close clouds.
Uh, an infinite multitude of syphilis.
Patients Clog London's hospitals and
more filtered in each day without
antibiotics. Victims faced the full
brunt of the disease, open sores,
nasty rashes, blindness,
dementia, and patchy hair loss.
Baldness swept the land.
Whoa.
He was still rocking
these things at the time.
Hair loss was a one way ticket
to public embarrassment.
Long hair was a trendy status symbol and
a ball dome could stain any reputation
because they knew you had syphilis.
All my God.
When Samuel Pepys brother
acquired syphilis, the diarist,
what does that word diarist he writes
the areas for a living that said he does.
Or is it generally in the dairy
business? The first one. Well,
we'll Google it after we read
this. Okay. The diarist rope.
If my brother lives,
he will not be able to show his head,
which will be a very great shame to me.
Wow.
So this year was that big of
a deal because we were bald.
You were made fun of what
they do back then. Well, yeah,
that's true in the Bible.
You know,
God sent,
sent some bears to kill some kids because
they made fun of this dude for being
bald. Those part of the
dark shit. Hmm. So, uh,
Louis the 14th hired 48 wig makers
to save his image five years later.
So this was Louis. The 14th was
only 17 when his mop staff. Odd.
Terrible genetic. Yeah.
Not Good. Um, Louis Louise,
cousin Charles.
The second did the same thing when
his hair started going to gray.
Both men likely had syphilis.
Courtiers courtiers hmm.
I don't know what that word is.
And other aristocrats immediately
copied the two kings. Ah,
interesting.
They split it.
Wigs in the style trickled
down to the upper middleclass.
Europe's newest fad was born.
The cost of wigs increased and perks
became a scheme for flaunting wealth and
everyday wig cost about 25
shillings a week pay. Wow.
For Common Londoner.
So a couple grant for this fucking wig.
The bill for large elaborate Perutz
ballooned to as high as 800 shillings.
Whoa.
The word big wig was coined to describe
snobs who could afford big puffy Peru.
Still use that. Wow.
Poofy wig. That's crazy.
When that was from the 17 hundreds
when Lewis and Charles died,
wig stayed around like some story.
This is crazy.
Proofs remained popular because they
were so practical. They're so practical.
That's why I say about wigs
are so practical. He said,
this is just the thing to do
at the time. Head lice. Oh Wow.
Headlights were everywhere and nitpicking
was painful and time consuming wigs.
However, curb the problem, lice
stopped infesting people's hair,
which had to be shaved
for the proof to fit,
so everybody's shaved their head
and wore a wig. I said, no home.
They camped out on the wigs instead.
Delousing a wig was much easier
than delousing ahead of hair.
You send the dirty here piece to a wig
maker who had boiled the wig and remove
the knit.
That's where nitpicking came from.
The term nitpicking came from picking
the lies out of wigs, dropping some.
Damn.
This is just like when Callon does that
segment of your show dropping knowledge.
The first of all, you've got to
rename that. You didn't make it.
You got to rename that immediately.
You cannot say dropping knowledge.
We just can't. No. We should
call it to call him up.
We should call him up right now. Hey
Brian. Hey Brian. We've been talking.
We've been just no more drop.
When it's wonderful that you're sharing
these little tidbits of information,
but to announce that they're going to be
there in a segment and say we're going
to drop knowledge now you know why
your mats pops up out of the ground,
like a fucking check in the box or
you just regurgitate what hunter said.
He's like, what's up? And I had to get
drop knowledge. Do I have to do it?
So listeners when if they don't like
that to fast forward otherwise to just
spring it on you. So it's Kinda like,
you know, it's almost like an ad read.
So if you dig it, cool. Here
it comes. This is his or your,
cause I was getting to have the drop good
drop knowledge on it was mine because
he told them to start it
off as a segment. No, no.
I told them some of them are really
funny writer or interesting or fun. Yeah,
sometimes. Is it, is it a problem that
you used to do it in every episode?
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
So we'd be like in the middle of
talking about wigs in by, you know,
in France in 1940 and then it would go
off on this thing and kind of derail the
show. So I said that's interesting
though. Like if he told you that,
if he told you that, you'd be
like, wow, that'd be great.
No sprinkles in some stuff where people
like that's not true, man. So true stuff.
Oh, where's it, what's the not true
stuff? You know, it just depends on that.
So interesting. Yeah, it
just depends. So I figured,
might as well just label it so fans
know what's happening right now.
I'm not a fan of segments in
anything. Whenever he goes. Okay,
now we're going to go to the,
let's pretend you're a Mexican game
fan.
Well,
not a fan of like a thing that people
like do in the middle of a show. Well,
I mean, well it's for ours. You know,
we'll have our banter back
and forth like we have,
not for three hours because we don't do
it every day, but we'll do it. You know,
if he had the same person
every single day, it's tough.
Killed the three hours material.
You and I could do a podcast every day
for three hours, different animal Joe.
That's a Dev. You're talking
about you and just talk some shit,
some professional podcasts or say I'm
good at talking shit. It's what we do.
But are you saying cal is not, how
dare you? That's what he's saying.
What he's saying. I'm not saying
that we're into the same things.
You and I are under the same thing.
It's couns into you know,
but I'm in the same things.
A lot of the same things that into I'm
going down a weird road. You know what?
Listen Bro, listen, tell
the fascinating man.
But what would the current
events it gives us, Fred,
you know I started current events calendar
and keep up with current events like
he wouldn't know.
Um,
whatever today's current event
was like with pop culture.
Like he has no idea with what's going
on in the world because he's so into
history. That's where Jamie
comes. Exactly. Especially
if it's like black Twitter.
Yes, he is just on the ball. So
I'm kinda like, yeah, so exact.
So the idea is like Jamie introduced
you in a certain stuff like with sports,
like counter CNN sends out,
you know, whatever the fuck
he does. So I'll be like,
man, you didn't know. You know, people
flashes Dick. He's like, I have no idea.
Well he's into books and stuff,
which is admirable,
but that's why the show
works is he's into his thing.
I'm into my thing and cross pollinate,
cross pollinate because Paul is he, how
much is Brian into like MMA these days?
Uh, I don't know, like
the, and that's the,
that's the one of the reasons
why I started my own show
because I'd be like, Hey,
did you watch that fight we are covering?
He'd be like, no, I didn't see it.
Or you just see the
highlights. And I'm like, dude,
I'm getting balls deep into this.
We kind of have to,
if you're a fighter and the kid and you
grow like this giant MMA population of
like listeners. Yeah. But
you know, for a reason,
maybe he's busy or somebody who just
see the fights. It's tough when,
and that's how my show started.
I'd be breaking down a fight,
can pretty intricate into it and he'd go,
so you know,
just some beginners where I
couldn't really get into it.
You don't get, they left.
These motherfuckers know
this Saturday is January 2nd,
this Saturday,
January there is a January.
I did this because I'm thinking
of who's fine. I'm sorry.
I'm throwing triple tasking, podcasting
thinking and going through a taxi. Um, no.
Um, the Saturday, the second is UFC
fight night. It's definitely true.
Versus who is it to pull it up to
have a mother fucking fight companion.
That's the point, ladies
and gentlemen. But um,
we are not going to do a companion
for Edmonton because I uh,
that's why do they still have Jermaine
Germane to me on there? She slide.
The fight did shout she got
injured. She about, yes.
It's pulled out unspecified reasons by
the, it's speculated that it's an injury.
Speculate. It has to scale. Scale.
Well Hashtag maybe cyborgs
going to be attending.
Yeah. Okay. Yes. From placement,
late replacement for injured,
Germane to randomly, uh, Talita.
The Olivera has apparently agreed to
step in on short notice. Who is she?
Have you seen her fight before? I'll,
let me see the rest of the cards. Yeah,
let's go back to the card. All right,
here we go. What's the full card here?
Volkov uh, yeah. Yeah,
he was very good too, man.
He beat his last fight.
He beat Roy Nelson to
kind of a light card.
I'm just being honest. Feel like light
would be an understatement. Yeah, I agree.
Like Ooh,
but wait a minute.
Bev [inaudible] him off his fighting
and then you also got, uh, uh,
Calabar yeah.
Um,
click on that tie ties him off fight.
He has,
he's been out of the UFC for a while.
He's in the UFC fight pass prelims.
They go right there. Bam.
Yeah. Philippe's Silva.
I'm mayor back ties him off. Is a very
good fighter. She's very good. That's,
that's going to be an interesting fight.
I don't know too much about Philippe
Silva, but uh, this is Rotterdam, right?
This is where this is taking place.
That made a to be fun.
It's Callen town I think so we got to
get Eddie Bravo drunk and bring up the
conspiracies.
That never happens.
Um, all Bob Arena is fighting. That's
who's he fighting right next to that one.
That's borrower does not. Was that
uh, uh, Brian Barberino Liana Edwards.
Jamaica. Bam, Bam. Um, yeah.
You know, it's like God,
but I will watch it and I'll see
what we do. It's tough motherfucker.
I like watching him fight. Yeah,
that should be interesting.
Yeah, that'd be fun.
Either way.
A lot of these new spiking a fight pass.
Did you see your boy snoop Dogg
Tuck Shit to Conor McGregor?
No. So did he do, what did he do? Oh
my God. Can you bring that up Jamie?
How did his, how the UFC doesn't go
get the fuck off to his face. No,
he put blast sound. The Instagram real
fuck you. It, that's what happens.
A little bitch all like just oh know
snoop Dogg trashes Conor McGregor and
profane tirade.
Really? Kayla's here. This 1 million
views by the way. Ooh. Powerful.
No
mother fucking punk ass bitch
motherfucking shit. Nigga. Nigga.
That's what you get coming
to a motherfucking gang
fight with a butter knife.
Your bitch ass mother fucker.
Fuck you Nigga.
Shit Nigga.
What a party.
Yay.
Hi honey.
I got one.
I got one more report.
50 no Nigga named
macgregor bad motherfucker.
He got hard. He got horn. Oh fuck.
Well okay. What happened there?
Did you get schizophrenia?
Xe bipolar is a bad Malia.
One more rev left.
Wow.
Come on man.
I just don't get when people
celebrate like inside me.
The demise risky took.
It was a fun fight.
The war brought the fight to Floyd and
it made it a fight is the biggest fight
of all.
Before we brought the fight to Connor.
I mean Floyd step forward with his hands
up and move towards him and constantly
created pressure. Kiandra also came
forward to man like they both brought it.
It was a very good fight. It was
very entertaining, very entertaining.
He hit Floyd more than any fighter hit
him and I think the right result took
place. A specialist, the
greatest specialist of all time,
beat a guy who is just not at his
league when it comes to that specialty,
you know?
I mean,
I think that's what we should have seen
and I think it was good for everybody.
I think it was great for Floyd because
there's the most entertaining Floyd fight
ever,
right?
It was a a great opportunity for him
to showcase his ability and to show
everybody what he can do.
I can get the 50th Win, get
the 50th win, and for Connor,
he got to show people that he
can hang for till he gets tired.
He can hang pretty well with
the best fighter of all time.
This is what else I think is cool is
Connor's going to take those boxing skills
and now bring it to the UFC.
Oh, and he's been on, there's,
there's no fight UFC can throw to
them that's going to be bigger.
There's just nothing.
You're not going to rattle him.
The moment can't get big enough for him.
So now, unless they give him Jon Jones,
Brock Lizard, like a tag team, some weird
random shit, which would be awesome.
However, there's nothing
they can do. Right. So now
he's learned from this. He's,
and he's a guy who learns from his
losses and brings that to the UFC.
I think he maybe has one, maybe two
left. But still you think so? Yeah.
I don't see him too. I mean when you have
100 million in the bank, he even said,
he goes,
unless I fucked things up,
I should be set for life and my kids and
their kids should be set for life. Yeah.
Yeah. So and he's very, you know,
self conscious of, you know,
the repercussions of sticking
around too long. He had a buddy,
he was a 10 of fight, a guy died.
So you know, I don't seem this.
The other thing with John being out now,
all the chips are in Connor's corner.
He's the only superstar, legit
superstar in town. He's like, listen,
you want me to fight again? I know that's
the old contract. This one I'm worth.
What do you guys want to do this?
The only way it's going to happen to him.
There is no second. Who else has
number two? Name a number two.
Joe [inaudible].
It might be steeper and that's time.
I mean he's the heavyweight champ.
I mean at least it's not
the doing kind of a global,
they're not even the same relevance.
He loves beside of the plan as far as
far as the draw. Yeah. Who else is there?
Who Bisbing who? George Saint
Pierre. Once you fight the Biz, Bang,
it had George and then people are going
to be a little disappointed with the
George numbers. I don't think
you can sell to all as you think.
I think the people that were
George Saint Pierre fans,
that's a long time ago,
over four years ago and the
sport is a different sport now.
You're talking to a lot of younger
people now that are just getting into it.
I like this old guy. It's fine. Cool.
He's fighting business doesn't really
make sense. Why? I'm the other guys.
I read this too.
She preview of the fight.
It was so douchey.
See the thing about that you see getting
bigger and some it's these fucking
sports guys who write these
really creatively negative
articles and it was about
the Bisping and you're saying you have
to read a Promo for the fight? Oh No, no,
I read it. Oh God, no, no,
no, not, I don't read promos.
When you see those promos, he's fret top
of the joint. 100% I don't have a plan.
I just say exactly what I think about
the fights. So like when I do those,
the best way to do it,
and I remember you telling me that.
So when showtime wanted me to cut a pro
for right before the fight, I was like,
let me just sit down and do it, man.
I don't want, just don't tend with do,
let me go. Let me think about what is at
stake, what is, what's it really means?
What's it mean to me? Like how do
I feel about, let me just go man.
And now shine through.
You know,
like when you talk about certain moments
that you've seen out of a fight or that
you show that shows like how special they
really are. It gets me excited. Yeah.
Like when you talk about like Anderson,
when he front kicked Vitor Belfort in the
face, like it was all electric moment,
you know that he's capable of doing
these movements that just look so much
faster and so much more accurate
than you expected. You know,
Anderson in his prime, some of his
performances, man, which is so stunning.
Now when I'm talking about back,
I like the, I don't need a what?
You tell me why I know
more than you guys do.
Who wrote this now and I'll tell you,
I'll tell you what I feel.
Nobody ever wrote anything
for him. No. Yeah, I bet.
So it should go away from the beginning
and that's why it comes off so good.
Yeah. When you hear a guy like reading
off a teleprompter and the beginning of a
fight, like the promo, the fight,
like when they're talking about what,
what's happening, what's at
stake, it just doesn't feel right.
Even if it's like kind of
crazy talk like teddy atlas,
like when Teddy Atlas least see
it's real. It's real. It's real.
You got to have real,
it's some crazy shit,
but it's really reading off
teleprompters is just paroled on what?
What was the thing you read though with
Bisbee and GSB [inaudible] on the fight.
It was just some
Douchey sports guy article
about it and I was like, ah.
It's saying that George Saint Pierre is
getting off his rocking chair to come
out and brown kick some. Nobody
in the head. I'm like, no, no.
He's coming out to fight George St Pierre.
Who is that car?
The stack.
George Saint Pierre Brothers coming out
of a retirement to fight Michael Bisping,
who's the UFC middleweight fucking
champion of the world widget midway.
He took it from Luke Rockhold like people.
You didn't say that you want,
but he still took the belt and then go
out, but the only defendant gets Dan him.
What? Who Cares Jed? He
beat him. He did? Yeah.
He's a legit straight lineage.
185 pound champ of the world.
You know, I don't, I just, when I
see that fight, I just add it again.
Go on my tours and just get seen.
The actual reaction face face
with fans when I talked about it.
It's very Luke warm. Yeah.
What do you guys think?
We got away for Robert
Whitaker to heal up, you know,
he's the interim champ and
that's going to be a while.
His knees pretty fucked apparently. So
he's got to heal up his name and you know,
once that's done then you know, you get
to see what happens after Bisbing fights.
GSP. Here's the thing though that
with, with Biz and I love busy man.
I wish she was a bigger draw, but
Bisbing ratio, not huge ratings.
Bisbing verse Robert Whittaker,
not huge ratings.
It's like there's nothing
you can really do.
The WHO's Luke Rockhold fight and again,
he's fighting uh, uh, David Branch.
That's right. That's an
interesting fight. That's system.
That's September what the 16th
or something like that. Yeah,
and they brand from world's Citi is fine.
His first fight in UFC was terrible,
but it's also his first, you know, in a
long time. He a world series champion,
light heavyweight and middleweight.
Yeah. So you know, he'll,
Gerald Harris knocked him out with a
slam and his first UFC fight weight,
rough UFC career left, you know,
did work and world series, you know,
for Luke Rocco. I think it's just, it's
more of him just getting back into things,
but he can't take this kid light.
No, no. Luxo talented man. Yeah,
he is so fucking silly. Talented. Yeah.
David Branch has won a
lot of fights in a row.
Lost Anthony Johnson by decision for,
that's pretty crazy.
Lost a loss as a light
heavyweight to Anthony Johnson.
Go Up to a Hardee's ripped his leg off.
He, yeah, he caught him though. Yeah.
And World series, right? Yeah. There
you go. No UFC. Oh, that's right.
He got heel hook. Quite
bad. Yeah. And he's a black,
he's a black belt on the
ground to second round. Huh?
One 44 I felt like I was the first round.
You just see 16 Paul Harris more
than once. No, just one time.
Yeah. Okay. Gerald Harris.
So that's where it is.
Gerald Harris knocked him out in UFC
one 16 lesbian Lesnar versus Carwyn.
Wow. It's a while ago. Fuck yeah,
that was, that's right. Kale Slam.
Yup. Yeah, I remember that.
I think that got knocked to the night
cause I thought I was gonna get it cause
that was really that kind
of knock out nine to slam.
I'm pretty sure that the Kale Slam weird
got an award for that. Interesting.
So score go up,
go up all the way to the top.
He has his hands full with the graph.
So yes he does. So he beat Vinnie,
who's a phenomenal submission artist.
Who else?
DP Christoph Jackto decent fighter
nine at the time or 10 at the time.
But that just shows you where
the middleweight division
split decision now he
beat on. Yeah, but you should know,
Cami has never been the same. He,
Jesse Taylor, who's
the, you know the champ,
but you should know Cami
after he got stopped by, um,
Tim Boetsch, Tim Boetsch and then
he gets stopped by Jacques Rey.
You got brutally stop bad then he
left. Yeah, he just wasn't the same.
And that's all, all of that is after
Anderson mark. Correct. But I mean,
you look at David Branch compared to
Luke rock colds lineup. It's insane.
Luke Rockhold.
I mean,
big difference in the world know this
is a terrible match up for David Branch.
And unless he can rise to the occasion
like that,
he wasn't talking a lot of shit
to each other to have a yeah.
Talking Alonda Shit.
Weidman.
Machida Bisbing Boetsch Philipo he
hasn't fought since December of 2000 Oh,
January of 2016 June. Sorry. The wild man.
And then before that he's
on the muckraker card.
When you fought Weidman Gregor Aldo, that
was the best performance of his career.
Beat the shit she hopes for that.
Two more that I thought.
I thought he looked at his best.
He also fuck the big thing up here.
I choked him out with one arm. Yeah.
Had kicked him to choke down a low.
Cut Him with that question mark.
Yeah. Applying and then Tim Boetsch,
you fucked him up with Tim. Tim Bullshit
fucked him up with an inverted triangle.
Kimora that cut. That has the
Philip who fight the body.
They have to talk Costa into walking out
to take that fight. Fight. Yeah. Why not?
He just didn't,
he was over it.
He didn't want to fight anymore
and my manager was like, dude,
if you don't walk out there, this will
take a career for the rest of your life.
Wow. And he was literally not
going to fight. He was like,
I'm not going to call his name.
He's like, I'm like going. Wow.
Aleks Mcmahon was like, you better get
your ass out there. I'm telling you, you,
you're going to regret this for the rest
of your life if you don't grab the why
did he not want to go out there? I think
he's just over it. The nerves, everything.
He was like, I don't wanna
do this anymore. Then Luke
Rockhold was like, here,
let me help you at Gish liver
kick get out of here. Yeah.
That's the business we're in. Oh
Shit. And he didn't want to go.
There's a decision that people make when
they've taken too much punishment and
then they just can't get excited
about performing anymore.
And it can't get up excited
about competing anymore.
There's a decision that people make
where once they make that decision,
you got to just get out because you will
never be the guy that you were when you
didn't give a fuck and you were hungry
and young and you're gonna run into that
guy, you're gonna run into that
guy, that guy that was you.
You're going to run into
him. He's there. Yeah.
He couldn't even tell what cost to Philip
who looked normal and that fight looks
like he's trying to win.
Think like once you get in there,
it's kind of fight or flight, you know?
Yeah. I mean it goes back to his instinct.
Oh boy. Luke Rockhold is a very good
left kick to the body. His Great, Oh,
who was illegal?
It's legal kick to the body when
you're on the grounds leading up, man,
that kind kinda hit his head, but yeah.
Did it. Yeah. Go back to your phrase. Dot.
Okay.
The very end of it.
Powerful Vimeo. Not that it mattered.
How's that? How's this legally online? Oh,
how dare you. Yeah, you're right. Right
behind the shoulder blade. That's legal.
Yeah. It's kind of weird that
you could do that. You're not,
can you stomp to body when he
goes down? Not really. Right? No.
You can ask kick though, Lupe.
Oh, that's right. You can,
can you like push stomp kicks
such bullshit in it. Can you like,
if you can't go down stomp,
but can you stomp forward?
You can do it on your feet because it's
kind of like a front kid. It's weird.
It's kind of dumb. Right?
That's weird. Anyways,
I think I liked it with brands where
I think Luke, Merck, so interesting.
But again, Luke's not a huge paper view.
Frolic for the UFC and champion out.
You're like, yeah, Luke has every
reason he should be. I don't get it.
But with John being out, just
go, go through the champs.
They got mighty mouse ain't happening.
No time. No time. They're banking them.
No Time's coming up.
So I had two fights.
Louie that for right in
the UFC. Yeah. Is it for,
I think he's had he fought Meesha?
No Sir.
Tim. He stopped. Um,
yeah. How many fights did you have
in the UFC? It's not pulling up.
It doesn't say, Oh yeah, just
go to his Wikipedia. I guess.
I feel like he's had two fights
in the UFC. Maybe said three.
Three of might have had three. Three. You
might be right. It's not a lot though.
I agree. It's not a lot.
There was this lady there.
Okay. Oh, as him split decisions.
Rose p. That's right. That's right.
That was a fight he took on short
notice. You Fun belts. I remember that.
That was in Houston. That's right. But
that's just been Merkin death. God,
he's just, but you look at the
division, there's just nothing for him.
So he has to fight desperate or DC.
Well, Merkin Misha is not as impressive.
All the Mishi has a very good striker
and a very good submission artist.
He's really good submissions.
But that was like, okay.
He caught that dude coming in, clipped
him with one punch, knocked him out.
That's oppressive. But doing it the Jimmy
man and why you got to go, oh, okay,
this guy's fucking for real.
Like if he could do that to Manoa,
he could do that to a lot of people think.
Yeah,
I want to see him do
it to someone else too.
Obviously you want to see
him fight next level stuff.
You know what I think's going to
happen and I do like him. I chill.
I hope he comes champ.
Be hilarious for many of reasons,
but I think you know his technique of
Russia and like that you get to a certain
level where it has like
DC and Gusto and go,
you want me to do what I think
get fucked up. Well that's,
we can see that led to it.
But here's the thing about that level.
There's levels to this game and light
heavyweight goes DC, John Jones,
Gus van DC and then and the second level
and then after that I can free for all.
Yeah, like what does DC do now? Like if
they give him back this high low again,
it's tea, but this is the thing in the
public's eyes, it's such a tough sell.
Like here's the best light
everywhere. World new ones like, nope.
We've seen him lose twice.
Now we see him get put to sleep by John.
The second fight you want
worst case scenario for you.
And I think DC's the late every, all
the time we take out. John, do you want,
you want to tell you what we're
skipping now they go tainted,
Supplement Dick pills again,
six months, a set suspension.
We're going to strip the belt from ya DC.
Here's about you gotta fight John
Again. Six months. Go get you something
here.
Just give me that Goddamn belt back.
Give me my fucking dealt that like
that's okay. But here's the thing.
We don't know what was really going on
now, right? We don't know with John. Yeah.
Now I think we are allowed
to have complete open
speculation with zero concern
for being respectful. Yes. I think after
the Dick pulled thing, I go, look man,
they do was party and he was taking
some Dick Pills. It's like, oh, coke,
I don't give a fuck about coke.
That's not helping you.
Then you hear about this and you go,
wait a minute, something's going on.
What is this? Yeah. I want
to know what this kid's like.
JDS got flagged right and they
pulled them off France, you know,
I only get jds go, come on. All
right. That's steroids for sure.
Because he's at a clean history with
John. It's one thing after another. Well,
jds also got flagged for a
diuretic. Yeah. I'm just saying,
let's say they didn't say
anyone's was trace amounts,
trace amounts, but with jds,
again, benefit of the doubt. All right.
It happened once, whatever, but John,
it's like come on Bro.
And then and then with the Dick Pills,
a lot of people are like, ah, that's kind
of covering up the third row, you know,
recovery therapy for when your
on intestines, testosterone
and stuff like that.
Like that's a little shady, whatever.
Put that to the side. Now it's like,
come on man. Well this is a
weird one because this one is,
if he was taking what you describe as
some short acting quick leaving your
system, steroid, some drug that makes
you aggressive, you've got to go. Okay.
How long was he doing as far I did.
Was He doing this during training?
This amp him up,
this help his work rate.
Did this make you more aggressive
and more confident in training?
Did it add to his confidence when
he was fighting? Like what is this?
We don't know. We were, we know
that story that shale son told,
you know that story of the Chelsea and
told them my podcast about John being
under the entire,
like under the octagon when the,
when the Sata kicked him out of luck
and pissed under that gun right there.
This is what they wanted to
do. They, they knew that he,
this was before you had to
expose your whereabouts.
He didn't have to disclose
your whereabouts back then.
So when they showed up at the gym,
John Apparently saw them pull up
and went underneath the octagon.
He thought they would leave.
They didn't leave.
They stayed the entire time
and they waited for the gym
to close the gym clothes
to shut the lights out.
And then John came out of the office.
He's crust chill and says chills is
really not a liar either. Besides,
if he's telling me he's not taking
steroids when he's fighting. Yeah.
I don't know if he got it from,
I dunno.
What source channels using,
he's pretty reliable, right?
He's definitely in the know,
right? I agree. I don't know.
I don't know if it's true or not,
but it makes
you think like, okay, well what is
that for? Is that for pot? You know,
Marty was, he wears a coat, cope with
their smoke. There's this much smoke.
I'm going to go, what's going on
here? Right. What is going on? Yeah.
How about jail sown and he, when
we had the press conference, he,
this is four days before the fight.
We're both work. He's working for,
I think ESPN for the Mayweather stuff. I'm
work for. Showtime comes by, he goes, Yo,
Max Kellerman they didn't
take you on $100,000 bet.
He'll win more than went around a more,
right. I went, no. He goes, I'll take it.
I went, jail. You take this bed, you're
going to fucking pay me. He goes,
I swear to God I will pay shakes my hand.
He goes,
if Mcgregor Mcgregor wins one round or
more, you give me $100,000 he goes, yeah,
he's not going to touch them.
He's not gonna win around.
Cool man. Shake his hand.
And after the fight,
he was literally like,
you just text me yesterday morning
because, hey bro, I'll be in la.
I dropped the cash off. I'm like,
you don't have to pay me, man.
It's not that sense. He was dead
serious. He, I'll drop the cash off.
You said no to a hundred
thousand dollars yeah.
He think he would have said no to
you. I do. He would have made you pay.
I do this type of fucking,
nope. I'm telling you this.
This type of dude chill is,
remember when Shaylin Nate [inaudible].
Nate fell on hard times.
Chail set without Nate Marquardt
pipe markup. Yeah. Yeah.
Sending him a check in the mail. It
was, I can and go through hard times.
Here's some money.
So when he helped my friend,
like he's always had a free pass with
me. Oh, that's really nice of you.
Very nice of you. It muscle rich.
Whoa, just kidding. Not Rowing in.
That's crew g one screw g here,
but now lots of Conor McGregor rich.
Who is these days? Whoa. Connor one
fight. Richard a new son. How about Floyd?
Alan? He's a billionaire, but yeah,
Floyd is probably worth like
$500 million now or something.
But they said that he owed money to the
IRS. I talked to him about that. He goes,
he was literally like, dude, my taxes,
it's, you know, it's the same equivalent.
If they flagged us. He's like,
you pay like whatever, 5,000 just,
I make so much money. I owe 5
million. I can pay it whenever.
It just got blown up in the news. He's
like, no one's broke here for God's sakes.
It's like a legit point, sir. Good
point. Go ahead. Someone was watching.
He can keep up that lifestyle though.
Would that kind of
spending spending's insane.
It's not Johnny Depp Insane.
Like there's Johnny Depp.
Remember we've been over that.
That's some shit ball like 14 houses.
There's Johnny Depp and say,
and then there's Floyd. Johnny.
How about two about two houses.
Floyd Mayweather become boxing's
first billion dollar fighter.
Can you name the other billion athletes?
Uh, tiger woods. Michael Jordan,
tiger woods, which was surprising
me. She got 500 million.
Come on. At least that'd be a
savage. Nah, she savage. But taxes.
If you don't really have a
billion when you have a true,
you have a shitload of money.
She got a hundred [inaudible].
She had two Hundo.
Ooh,
that bitch crazy too. In this car
with clubs and shit. Wow. Well,
he kind of deserved it. Made me, she gets
a little upset. So you got Arnold Palmer,
Jack Nukes and tiger.
Michael Jordan
made a billion knocking out a little ball
off that dirt off that delicious drink.
Oh, that's right. No,
no, I'm just kidding.
Tiger Woods estimated at
100 million chunk chunk.
It's a lot. It's a lot
of cash. Baby baby sat.
That's a lot of cash.
Bay Bay, Bay Bay set.
Did you see that video and tiger got
arrested for drunk driving. You know,
it's hilarious. He's just fucked
up on pill he was on. Did you see,
I think they found six things in a system.
Why did he drive on pain pills?
Because tiger woods who told them tiger
woods but doesn't he know like, Bro,
you just got back surgery and you're
taking like heavy duty opiates or whatever
the fuck they're given that he's taken.
What was he taking?
He was taking a barge or ship
a fulls eyes or show fuck dude.
Time Shave your head. Take it
from another bald guy. Let it go.
It's like that song from the movie
frozen. Let it go. Let it go.
Can you just got to ditch that shit?
Yeah.
I mean he's not good looking guy anyway.
He terrible bro.
He would worry about that
nonsense you got going on there.
Just go ahead and wear glasses.
If I was to Cochise too, man,
like you have $1 billion bro.
He gets 100 million but clear
glasses that Connor was wearing.
Some of those like Dave Chappelle's
went some that I definitely want to get
there.
It was like a brown for frame and they
weren't so dark where their sunglasses,
they were like tinted were look cool.
You get those. If you have a cock guy,
know what the move is.
He goes with like yellow aviators,
hunter s Thompson style,
and just starts dressing like Johnny
Depp and just starts flaunting the fact
that he's a freak.
I agree that your freak
flag fly fricking freak go.
So he's tied to the system and all that.
And of course more all that's true.
Nike's still fucks with the money.
A lot of people do.
No really good companies even after
this. Yeah. Do you remember how big,
do you remember how Big Tiger
Woods was gone? Thai? Yeah. Again,
made golf like cool. Yeah. That's the
guy I saw my house out in that bitch.
Oh my God. He had Vikatin.
Yeah, and dilaudid. Jesus
Christ. He was taking some shit.
They gave people that were dying of
like bullet wounds in the old west days.
Miladin and Xanax. Christ.
You know what? Hey Man.
Andy say a sleep, drugs. Xanax.
Xanax is not asleep truck.
So it's a relaxer, right?
Like anything. Anti Insomnia, drug
ambien. Why did they say sleep drugs?
Zanuck no sleep track is ambien.
You dummies.
You Xanax is an antianxiety.
Either way. It's proof.
He likes to party. Yeah, man, that's
a lot of shit. Go back to that place,
but he doesn't really play golf anymore
yet. He does, but he's not doing good.
He was found unconscious
in his Mercedes Benz,
which was parked awkwardly on the
side of the road and had damage to the
driver's side. What are you
doing? He hit a bunch of shit.
Did you hear how he fucked up his back
and knee? Have you heard this story?
No. He was upset because his father was
the military. He's obsessed with military.
He actually trained with Navy seals,
like put on the full thing.
Went through this navy seal train,
like obviously not real shit but doing
all the marches and shit and fuck this
stuff up. That's how I
fucked himself up. No,
it's one of the ways he fucked his
knee and backup was like intense,
like navy seal training, like shooting
with them and stuff. That's so stupid.
The secret history of Tiger Woods,
is that what it's in there?
Fire article.
The death of his father set are a battle
raging inside of the world's greatest
golfer. How he wage that war through
an obsession with the navy seals.
It's tell the tale of how tiger lost his
wet. I haven't read this either. Wow.
Yeah, man. There's a thing.
I agree that you have to have mental
toughness to work out hard and to get
through brutal workouts.
You have to, you have to,
don't gotta go navy seal on a bitch
though. That's what I'm saying.
I'm saying you got to build your body up
to that and you are a different person.
You're a fucking professional athlete.
You're not a warrior.
Going over to cs to take bullets,
fight for your life and kill bad guys.
What you're doing is a very specialized
thing that it's worth a fucking billion
dollars. And you're also hitting
that little tiny ball on this calm,
quite golf course.
I don't need you to be in the waves
trying to learn how not to drown and fight
sharks.
It's like taking a dude who bought a brand
new Ferrari and taking them on one of
those crazy dirt courses that they have
those a off road Porsche's drive on.
You know those, uh, you've seen
those things. Those guys are like,
they have one guy next to him.
I never,
I need to ask someone what
the fuck they're doing.
I just have like Chris Harris on.
I'll ask him.
There was another guy with a notepad.
He'll rally cars the map and he's
going to clicks left turned right.
He's as navigator. Yeah, exactly. He
knows the whole course like dead on.
Who's reading it off a book?
Yeah.
Or just use mapquest says
those guys are maniacs.
Pull up some video of a rally drivers
or get rid of the fucking dead weight,
telling you the directions. Use
mapquest with the boys. You can't,
but they could step up their APP.
Gaming. Do something. You have to have.
That guy needs a job.
He's job studies.
The Colin's taking care of the
guy with the fucking notepad, but,
and he knows like how long it
takes for you to get there too.
Because if you're driving it,
you're fastest.
Even if you're off our five
or six seconds, you're in.
The neighborhood knows what's
up. Those guys are wild, man.
Those cars are so it's like
such a different style of
driving because the dirt
makes the,
the tires break loose like constantly.
Have you ever considered going
that the Porsche track here?
We can take all the cards
though. Let's do it. I know.
Don't they have a new one near the lax?
They have a new one not far from here,
but the guy was telling me that like
great restaurants. He's like just book.
It will take care of the car.
They take care of the Thai.
No notes go cars flat out scrooge.
Mcduck sample edibles.
Give that gt three Rs while it's fried.
Some go need some copilots.
Let me do my thing. I come on.
Don't go full circle all season on us.
Yeah, we can. This guy 61 now.
Holy Shit. They must be fast friends.
Jesus dust flying. They're best friends.
You'd have to be best
friends. Hey Bro. Wow.
This is nuts man.
See that red light?
Yeah. That is a, a sequential
manual. It's a manual,
but you, you just push up to
go up and down to go down.
You don't have to find out here. Good
speed, right. The quickness. Yeah.
Yeah.
You don't have to find
the perfect year,
you know,
give,
you're using that h pattern.
You're going up and then you go on
down and you go up to the right. Yeah.
So it's down three down, two
up one. You know, the, the,
the way you're doing it is,
it's very different.
Although my new Porsche Pete
Pdk will shit on this. Yeah.
Yeah.
It'll shit on it.
But this is probably more fun for this
not sitting in traffic on that road.
I assume that dead he traffic.
Yeah. I go down the canyon.
I just opened that bitch. I
have take some risks too. Yeah.
But it's not as fun as driving a manual
to me. If I, if it was like the one,
if I was driving in traffic all the time,
I would,
there's not a chance in the world.
I would want a manual.
You don't drive your gt three and the
four oh five sometimes not five in the
afternoon. Sure. I do. Really?
Yeah. Even like, Yup. Oh Wow. Yeah.
Well you just like,
sometimes it's like driving that thing.
I just want to drive me to like sometimes
I'll take the long way home or at
night I'll just jump on the Pacific
coast highway 2018 BMW m five pack 600
horsepower and m x drive
all wheel drive system.
Woo 60 and 3.2 whoa.
That's a big car to pay for the extra day.
That doesn't top out at like 140 it'll
it tops out at one 11 unless you pay for
the package.
BMW needs step their game up though.
I feel like they're losing the
battle with everyone else right now.
Well they say Sadie's is just [inaudible].
It's definitely ahead of them.
You know what BMW has coming out though?
An eight series.
The eight series a sedan.
Divina back.
Do you remember you she removed the eight
50 yeah, the front end. They were all,
she wants to have one of those.
Katie who's got a them to the comic store
back in those days are a nightmare now.
But yeah, look at this new one though. Oh
Shit. Go full screen sun. Look at this.
What? You're only seeing the front
of it. Wait till they go on the side.
Look what this thing looks
like. It's wicked bad. Damn.
That's like an I eight but not
the electric version. No, no, no.
It doesn't look that space. Shippy
no, no, no. You know what it's like,
it's like the BMW or the Mercedes
s class coupe. Yeah, those are,
that's what it's like and it's
this, the big body. Um, uh,
I'm assuming a twin turbo. I don't know
what the fuck that's got under the hood.
I think all their cars are turbo
like date 50 back in the day.
Look at the back end though.
Damn. Nothing is bad them here.
They'll spin around that. I
ate pissed. That's a tron car.
I test drove that. They're like,
get the fuck out of my face man.
Too many different colors too. And you
know what? It's going to skinny tires.
Yes. Can't fuck it. I need fat tires. I
don't even like the tires on the corvette.
How about that? I need some fat
ass tires even though the will,
the drug room dynamic. Shut your
hole. I liked the way it looks.
I like fat acids and fat tires and Tig
old biddies fix 10 nothing is dope.
Pretty sick. You used to have the m six
right? Yeah, them six I think it was fun,
right?
Nothing was a monster heavy straight
up v 10 heavy smoothed down highway.
Right? Yeah. Nothing fun in the tribe.
Now that Porsche gts is, you know,
they say that's the best of the Porsche's.
There was a article that I just read
in one of the car magazines that said,
uh yeah, see if you can find rag
to my friends. Go to a Porsche.
GTS is the best Porsche.
It's like a very recent article that I
actually read this morning on Google type
move. Yeah, they were saying that
it's the best version of it. You know,
you've got your gt three
which is like super hardcore.
I test drove that room and I called you.
I was test driving the gt three and I'm
like, Joe, you love this thing. You said,
unless you got another vehicle,
man for you drive every day is a bad idea.
You'll get loud and get it to pull.
The GTS is low too.
I escaped the Front for Felony
Crime. So another interest. So,
but the gt three has a button that raises
yeah, yes. Front end. The GTS does it.
Well it's not the GT three.
It does because you buy it that way.
[inaudible] options that will option
wasn't there. But tech art makes um, a a,
an aftermarket one so you can get that
and get it installed and it'll raise it
up. I know a bunch of Porsche
dealerships that do it. Yeah.
My gts, yes. My gt three
has an aftermarket.
Oh my gt three saved the day I have to
park on the street cause my driveway's
like this. Yeah. I had
to take one of my, um,
one of my other buttons from something
else and have a dedicated to that,
a gt three button.
I matter of fact,
I think they took it from a blank
and they installed a button in it.
You have a blank where you can put it.
Mine's right on my, uh, my
rear view mirror. Rather when
I go, uh, near something,
I'll hit that button.
It was the best car on earth.
What did you say was a Porsche gts?
2018 Porsche gts is the best. Uh, nine 11,
they were saying they
were just going over like,
it's like hardcore but not too ridiculous.
I got a gt three Rs and that it's
pretty slick. Do you see that one guy?
He spent a shitload of money
to take you as the Porsche.
That brand new gt three Rs is only um,
PDK.
They don't make it in a manual.
Says guy spent a shitload of money to
have a six speed from a Porsche nine 11
are installed in a gt three rs cost
so much. He must just be scrooge.
[inaudible] screwed,
screwed up all the Porsche.
But if you even have one of
those things, that's it. Pull up,
pull up the top of the article.
What does it say? Quick take,
not the fastest nine 11, but possibly
the best. When is it from August.
Yeah. The things that today's
fun. Yeah, that's it. Yeah.
Well it's not the fastest though.
The nine 11 turbo turbo so that things
are God damn space machine like that.
This time. Have you test drove one
yet? 2007 or 2000 I'm not seven.
Uh,
2009 or 10 I drove one.
The new ones that I test drove
faster, the gt three and that, yeah,
I was just in love with my car so fast.
There's stupid fat and they're four
wheel drive, but the new ones even fast,
way faster than that one.
The one that I drove her insanely insane.
The GT three.
It's just you. I felt like it was like
hard, but yeah, so hardcore that you,
you would love the turbo if you got one
of those new turbines, you'd be like,
what in the five test drove that
and the gts gts module with that. I,
there's my, cause my car, it's like that
lava orange, it has the duck wing on it.
It's just like a vintage
Porsche to me like that. Right.
I saw on the show them right
away. I'm like, that's it.
I'll look at these own that. The
judge. No, I'm like that's it.
I test drove g three everything and I,
I just let him know doc wing the duck.
Cause when I was a kid I always had saw
a poster for a Porsche and had the old
school doctors green and I forget
how to duck wing on it. I'm like,
that has a duck way. Yeah. That's
like, and that's important. 73 Rs.
It's so cool man. You know those cars was
1973 RS is a worth over $1 million now.
So sick. Like why if you bought it
back in the day was like 20 grand.
Now it's worth $1 million.
Why don't you do you,
aren't you doing some with a Porsche
school porch? Not that old school.
So 1988 [inaudible] 86 or something.
Shark words. Just turn the
thing into bay. It's a um, uh,
an rs America and nine, six, four, just
like one of the last, the air cooled cars,
the last, the air cooled was the nine,
nine three, which is like a little bigger.
This is a nine, six, four. The air cooled,
everyone's obsessed with isn't shown.
It's just a different animal. And you
get them pretty cheap too. You know,
they're just not,
it's not.
It's different kind of car and if you go
earlier than that, you get me cheaper.
You can get them pretty cheap for
like the 1980s cars. I seen him.
I seen that one that I found.
It was a 78 Kirra and island,
but it had some reconstructive
like stuff to it look fun.
It's a bad investment because
it's like, oh, I saw that car.
You send me a picture of it. I want
that. Yeah, those are ass crazy man.
Those things through dangerous.
Do you know about how to
drive house like you when you,
when you take taking turns you
have to keep your foot on the gas.
I know there's no,
if you let off the gas they have throttle
overstay like what does it call the
throttle led off oversteer or something.
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to go out like
James Dean. That's exactly
what it was. Silver too. Well,
they're really light. Yeah, I know.
They looked fun. They feel different.
Like my friend Alex from shark
works has a nine six, four and his,
it feels different because
they're so small. It's like it's,
it's you're more connected
to what you're doing.
It's really light and really small,
which is cool. Yeah. Swishy this day,
like going down to paying a cane.
I'm not using it every day.
Cars think it'd be fun and I want
a new bronco as a daily driver.
The new, new, new new one. You seen
that thing? Why? What's up? Oh,
and juice and I live over by their,
what's up?
Who was going to buy the juices? Car.
They got to put that up for sale,
but an auction company just passed
on it and they go on for 350,000
the actual like rides three 50
why and all this? I have no idea.
You'd have to be a ghoul.
You'd have to be a real long task.
Can you imagine if I drove it? What is
it, dude? This is the car. No, Jay cut.
You're an asshole. We can't
be friends anymore. Yeah.
Oj Simpson's White Bronco Escape car.
Wow.
It goes on sale for $700,000 as a former
agent decides it's time to cash and
decides it's time to cash in.
Right when Oj is getting out of jail,
I was just going to kidnap this dude
and go back to jail cause this guy sells
his Bronco for 700 grand. That's his
fucking whip, man. He's going to stab you.
It looks pretty good shape. I
like the wheels. Right? Right.
Should we get it as like a company car?
Some shit.
$700,000 that is the cost
saying what year was it?
[inaudible] 93 right? No, it can't
be new. It wasn't new at the time.
I don't think God [inaudible]
94 police chase. What years?
The coffee like the car's 93 does it
say 89 Bronco? Does that sound right?
Yeah, it sounds right in the nineties
Bronco. My pops hasn't been since Bronco.
They're smaller.
Huh?
My Dad had an Eddie Bauer 92 telling you
my pops had an Eddie Bauer Bronco and
the thing was tiny. I remember the
Eddie Bauer ones was like, Whoa,
what is this weird like what do you fly
fishing and why is this Eddie Bauer?
Yeah, it had this cool trim
on it. My Dad would say,
Eddie Bauer like was a big deal.
God Damn,
it's up for sale on pawn stars now.
That'd be on pumps.
Probably made some extra cash.
I've already seen it.
The pawn star guy turned it down. He
did? Yeah. He didn't want it could move.
He said, I don't want that bad
Juju. Am I below that song? Well,
there was blood in that car,
man. Was it? Oh judge. Yeah.
Yeah. He cut his own hand with
the knife, allegedly. So sketchy.
Did you see him get a released?
Like when they only gave him parole?
Did you wash that was crunk
and will just judge you did.
It was like a huge football fan.
Do you know that?
But this is saying it's amazing shape.
I drove it around and found a little odd,
but it runs great.
You found a little odd.
Did it smell like murder if it
smelled like dead bitches? God,
Bro. I watched it live. I was in
Italy. I wasn't gonna miss it.
I was like, I need to see
this. Oh, getting out. You
don't have him on the podcast.
I joked around about it. I put it
on the podcast. I put it on Twitter.
Should I have him on
the podcast or na or na?
And Moshe Kasher was the first one to
respond. But she say Moshe, the comics,
they end up, it's a he. Oh, my
bat Natasha is that the watch?
But Natasha Moshe, that's tough.
Yeah, I get ya. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
I think he was like, oh good Lord.
Something, something along those lines.
I feel like it'd be so interesting. Well,
don't get me wrong, he completed burger,
but I feel like it'd be so answering
if you went down that route.
Like what have you been up to football
days, how the fuck did we get here?
He'll say, this isn't even a way how I do
it. Your warm up. Roll them up. Hey Val,
tell us how great you were at
football show you. Do you? Oh yeah,
maybe I can get them on the fire and the
kid. I don't know if that's platform.
Callan would be the
perfect gas to talk to him.
Calla definitely not interrupted him
and start talking about stories and he
played football or tell him
about the Thai. Perfect. Yeah,
it'd be actually counting him
together would be really interesting.
I thought I would. I would. I would
like to actually see that town.
Make him feel good to compliment them.
You know like [inaudible] one [inaudible]
don't say what you would
do. Never know man. I,
he might go on a podcast like
marketing thing. Look Bro,
my race definitely we're writing a
book. Is he get mad? Is it poor taste?
If I drive around Brentwood
and a brand new white, yeah.
No really for Halloween for sure. If
you like paint my face black. Yeah.
If you have like a Piko black face and
by catch a seat seatbelt clanging around
on the right girl wears a blonde
wig in the bag. That's poor taste.
See I'm not going that far.
I just want a dope ass brand
new Ford Bronco and white.
The new ones are pretty sick if they do
a good job with it. Have you seen him?
I've seen some. Um, what do they
call those things? Prototypes.
What do they call them? They don't
call it prototype. What's that word?
What does the word they use? Concept.
What? They look like the raptor. Well,
that's smart. Move the raptors.
Pretty Dope. So sick. Look at it. Ooh,
slick. See you. Imagine me that
like, I do like that. Right?
Who are they doing? A
four doors. Oh, okay.
What's going on in 2018 though?
Early two 18.
See that Cadillac right here was a god
damn bad ass car to Americans making some
kick ass cars. Now see that
Cadillac, right? They're
not though.
They're cool.
And Tigo from a Porsche or a Bentley
and the jump metallic. You'll all right.
Kind of basic. Yeah. Interiors or
basic. You're spoiled. Spoiled. I know.
The German was a little baby thing.
Gotcha. They got me. It's true. Right?
There's no American equivalent
to like a Mercedes s class.
They just don't quite get there. We just
went out there and it's not weird. Like,
why don't they get, they're like, why
doesn't someone just dig in and go,
let's just throw our fucking
Dick into this hat through.
Let's just get our dicks and then
the third here. Fucking yeah,
just build some beast of a fucking like
what's the best America Lincoln like
you'd get a Lincoln. No, because no one
cares. No one cares for the older crowd.
Yeah.
You show up at a Lincoln navigator.
Fuck shorty from 94 not a bad car.
The new ones are actually pretty nice.
I know, but the point is it's
not a Mercedes just cut. What?
American car can you pull up and
shit on people now it's comfy.
Nothing Eldorado now that
they don't have a viper,
you can't even pull up in a
sports car now. Old Demon.
I typed in American muscle
car and it's just muscle less.
You still kick ass. I'm
talking luxury car. Well,
they have the market cornered
when it comes to muscle cars.
When it comes to a stupid car with a
giant engine that makes a ton of noise,
we're killing it and it uses a
manual transmission marriage all day.
They still make the corvette.
Z O six in the fucking manual.
It's one of the few cars that Germans
are the only ones in the Porsche.
A Porsche is the only ones that have had
the balls to come bring a manual back
after they took it away.
Ferrari still hasn't figured it out yet.
They refuse to tell. Well, because
Douche bags it buy Ferrari's.
They're all just trying to floss. Trust
of them. Don't even know how to drive one.
Not Real. It's not. It's not a track car.
Have you seen that Porsche Turbo can buy?
It's like the platinum edition.
The wheels are made out of carbon
fiber and the whole it's gold. It's a,
it's like a dark,
like not like scrooge McDuck gold coin,
but it's like a gold color.
Bring that shit up dude.
It's this, it's this special
Porsche turbo like platinum edition,
platinum edition turbo,
but it's in gold.
How I wrote a goal and then it has
black rims that are carbon fiber. Dude.
Why is it platinum edition? But it's
in gold. Shouldn't it be in platinum?
It should be platinum. I Dunno. I
think he's scared this issue. It like,
remember when Justin Bieber had that?
That chrome Fisker Fisker fan.
I saw one the other death taught
brides split dope. It's dope.
Look in the catch on fire and there it is.
It's about my bat exclusive series.
Look at that thing.
Joe, buy this, buy this.
That's your niche, right? Look at that
thing. They're tough to get to. Are they?
Yeah, when I want it. Well cause
it was tough to get ones here.
Like still figure it out.
No, we'll figure it out.
I'm not driving a gold car
bro, Bro. That's not gold.
What color is it then? The
platinum edition. You are right.
The platinum edition a but it
adds another 66,000 under your,
it's your tag. That
exclusive series. It's fast,
luxurious and delightfully gold.
The beautiful special edition.
We limit it to 500 units worldwide. Hey,
guess what? When you make something cool,
make a bunch of 'em you assholes.
Now I'm going to buy them.
Make an exclusive only to have
it. I don't want it. Whoa.
Look at though.
That fucking thing is nasty.
Looking at zero to 60 times 2.8 seconds.
That seems excessive.
How's it going to get shorter than that?
You're not even three seconds.
You're going 60 miles an
hour because with those,
those new rims that are all carbon
fiber scope, how sick is that?
Those rims are dope. I was skeptical
at first. Those rims are killer.
I like the black stripes too.
It's a nice car,
but you know what a lot of people don't
like the way nine 11 turbos look like.
What did my friend when you get
into that cannot be my friend?
It's a first look at that
fucking car, Bro. It's bad ass.
The stripes on the seats. Ooh, that's
what it comes with. That luggage to Jamie,
Bro.
I would flaunt that everywhere.
Got Damage,
but it's like how much does it cost?
66 I think 66,000 over.
Well,
you get to watch Justin coop
and the $257,000 but no,
it's more than that, right? Ooh. Ah.
It doesn't come with the
five piece luggage. Another
sixth grade by that pitch.
6,000, 324 for the luggage service. Every
penny, how much you get for the watch.
Dope is that thing though.
It's nice. I prefer silver,
especially that thing that is a spaceship.
I mean your flex on people.
If you pull up in a cold pour,
a hundred percent match matching luggage
and I'll watch pull up in a red Ferrari
and double-flex you. I don't, not in
that thing. I feel like I've seen fries.
Yeah. I was in Italy and a guy
had a Ferrari in Italy. I'm like,
this motherfucker has a variety in
Italy. He went, it's pretty classy.
It was red right in front of this
beautiful hotel on the Amalfi coast,
on that guy is bald. And he probably had
something to look at that Jamie. Fuck.
Damn. Jamie Foxx. Jamie Foxx
has a shiny gold Bugatti.
He wins and a gold wheels.
His wheels are fucking gold.
He wins. Jamie Foxx wins.
Yeah, go back to, um, the, um,
the, um, what is the, um, the
new Ferrari? What does that they,
the fuck is it called? No, I'm
not. I'm not a Lamborghini Ferrari.
See, for me it goes Porsche fry.
I'm not laying McKeany guy. Yeah,
Lamborghini gets a little sketchy,
but I gotta say con,
they yelled when I see a guy and I'm to
guide. You probably have a small day.
Yellow little, yeah, the yellow little.
Yeah. It's just like, oh well, giant tool.
Check me out. Yeah. It's like
if you buy a Ferrari, Ooh,
that's a four eight eight special edition
Sun lighter with larger appetite for
Apexus. That's the like the race
version, but that's a shitty picture.
Go to a video. Ferrari for Aa like
that has a beautiful car, man.
That's exactly what the guy had in Italy.
That is a big thing,
but I'll tell you what, what it looks
better than that. The new Ford Gt,
that thing sick, that looks
better than that. That it,
that might be the American
Ferrari. Oh, it's,
it's based off the front to copy the front
of that thing. Go full screen, Jamie.
I'll take the hips on that pitch.
That thing is,
Ooh, Jamie, do you get this stuff? Does
this do anything for you? Get Boring.
You pause too hard. Yeah. I don't
think he's velvet ropes around.
The stupid thing won't let
me fucking get my Paul's.
Is this a club with a bottle
service or Goddamn car?
Cause I don't see any fucking drinks
around there. Yeah. Why? Where's the,
where's the car? And let me get
my hands on it yet things filthy.
It's a beast. Their budgets.
You know what they are.
Here's the thing there.
God Damn Gorgeous there.
They slip on incredible but they're
going to probably break. Yeah.
You didn't have some problems with it
with a Porsche. You never have problems.
Really.
Yeah.
It's like the difference between a girl
who does crossfit and she's got like
thick ass and big legs and his shoulders
are a little stacked and she a address.
Right.
Versus a girl who's like a model who's
going to turn an ankle if she goes to the
beach
with that other than say the crossfade
curls going to like eventually breakdown
cause crossfits and shit.
Now the crossfit girl is the viper.
That's the viper ACI burry. That fucking
Shitty for rock. You get that new viper.
That thing breaks race courses everywhere.
It's tiny. It's buried in that Ferrari.
Fuck you as it drives by sticks
is figure out the window.
When a kid rock song claims,
I mean that is not even close.
It's going to kill the Ferrari,
but the Ferrari's like sexier looking
like he's got perfect features.
It's got amazing shit goes wrong.
It goes wrong when it
comes down to fucking,
you're going to want that
crossfit girl kind of want.
I want that girl can push our way
through a spin class and I as the mental
toughness, just keep on, do a 90
minute cross or yoga class. Yeah.
You don't want a girl who's got like
perfect genes but she's lazy. No. Hell No.
And she just takes Adderall for a few days
before her big shoots. He doesn't eat.
Look at that thing. That's a Ford
Gt. That's a gross color though.
I saw one in a sick blue collar. It
looked amazing for tours. Killer fuck.
You look at the body on that
thing. No Color Dan. I'm out. Yeah,
find a better color Jamie. Fuck off
of this color. Those headlights on.
Do anything for me to
see in a better angle.
Give me the blue and white for God's
sakes is America for fuck sakes. Shave.
God Damn it.
I'm not a fan of red with
white red with white stripes.
I like red with black stripes. That
looks blue with white. That's right.
I like wait. That's America.
Like we think Margo.
Mark, what do you got?
Well, we'll look at this.
Oh, you nailed it. Jamie black with red
stripes. That might be put. Look at that.
Jesus Christ. Look with the exhaust
pipes come out in the back like that.
That that might be the best
looking car. Fuck, I got to agree.
That thing is sad.
That might be the best car ever.
Those giant Brembo brakes in the
front. I can't listen forward. Gimme
gimme a some manual not make
it hard to get right to.
Yeah, but it's also a double clutch. Come
on forward. You know Jay Leno has
probably got six of them that fuck. Yeah,
there's like 50 of them.
Jay Leno takes 10 j Seinfeld
takes 20 of them were all fuck.
Lebron James has got one and Bron
James might want to jump every house.
Kevin Hart jumps in your Kevin
Hart's got one minute on a gold damn.
Look at that thing though.
Holy Shit. That's the perfect
color jam. You nailed it.
Yeah, you've hit it black
with red stripes. I never
knew black with red stripes.
Like so bad ass and with
the lights in the back.
That's amazing looking.
It's sounds so good. There's
a lot of people right now.
Mad At us. Yeah, the pith,
the two of them cars again bro.
Hey,
we gave you three hours of Dicks and uh,
what else were we talking about?
Nate Diaz. Drama Diaz.
The Cardinal Gregor. Fine.
How about we went over Mars attacks.
That's right.
They'll get mad at us
because we like cars.
We talked about the shit we like about,
I really enjoy the automotive engineering.
We could bring this home. Let's bring
this bitch off this weekend folks.
Fight companion returns Saturday night.
Stephan sky straight per screw.
Struve's crew versus a Alexandra Volkov
right? That's his name. That's right.
And I'm in a COBB's comedy club,
September 14th and then I'm in Long
Beach Laugh factory, Long Beach,
September 22nd two fat k.com for
tickets and the comedy store.
That's right. Oh, Jesus. What a lineup.
It's probably sold out in Sam triple
he Sam triply show. That's right.
It's might be sold out already,
but if it's not, go online,
uh, it's on calm. Sure.
There. It's on the comedy store's
website and my Instagram on my Instagram.
All right. Love you guys, man.
Okay.